i guess the first thing i'd like to just
ask you is how you're doing
i'm doing great
so what's great what's great about what
what you're doing what's so good about
your life
well right now i'm in the process of
putting together my next stand-up comedy
special so uh i'm at the process now
where i've actually put together a full
new hour of material
since my netflix special which came out
in october so uh that's that's great for
me it's uh that's always a a relaxing
moment because it's very difficult to
put that hour together
and so it's and so how do you go about
doing that
a lot of writing a lot of performing a
lot of reading
a lot of going over notes a lot of
examining material a lot of reviewing
sets and trying to find out what i like
and what i don't like it's it's a long
and brutal process it's the it's the
most fun but also the most difficult
part of stand up is the creation of new
material so how many hours do you think
you put in of work to do an hour's worth
stand up
any idea
that's a really good question it's
usually about i can do a so i can create
a solid
10 minutes a month
that's usually what it is so it takes me
six months to do an hour and in that six
months on an average week i'll do
eight or nine sets
so that's uh eight or nine
either half hour or hours of material
sometimes 15 minutes usually an hour
depending upon where i'm working and how
many other people are on the show
and then a lot of time writing
so you're doing those sets in front of
live audiences all the time yes yeah you
have to that's that's the weird thing
about stand-up comedy it seems to be
that
it's it's not something that you can do
in a vacuum it has to actually be done
it actually it has to come alive in
front of the audience like i can i can
write in a vacuum i can write a loan i
can
contemplate go over my material review
uh
edit i can do all sorts of things by
myself but it really doesn't come alive
until it's in front of an audience
yeah well i guess it's not so easy to
figure out what's funny you kind of hope
that people will laugh
yeah it's that but it's also there's a
state of mind that you only really
achieve when you're performing in front
of an audience and you can try to
recreate it but it'll be fake
if you try to do it on your own like i
don't write
i don't write in joke form like i don't
write the way i say it on stage i write
in sort of a conceptual form
i write in an essay form and then i sort
of extract things that i think are funny
out of that but they really only
find their true
the true way i'm going to do them i only
find that in front of an audience
because it's like when the when i'm in
front of an audience then it it becomes
clear to me
how
i should and shouldn't say things based
in part on how they're reacting and
based in part on how i feel when i'm
performing the idea like i find where
the
fat of the bit is and that's where you
kind of
appreciate economy of words and you know
what to edit out and what to elaborate
on what people aren't totally
understanding and what maybe is over
explained and all that stuff kind of
comes together in front of an audience
so the essays that you're writing or the
writing that you're doing like are they
on serious topics are they on things
you're thinking about philosophically or
are you trying specifically to be funny
are you just trying to get some thoughts
down you know about the way you're
thinking about the world both
you know it's like the ideas
if it's
stan i always say the stand-up comedy at
least the way i do it it comes in three
forms like there's three steps in the
beginning you're really just trying to
get laughs you're just fighting for
survival out there you're scared that's
in the early days of your career then
you start doing
what you think is funny like things that
would make you laugh
but then in stage three
you start
trying to make ideas funny and you try
to cleverly introduce ideas into
people's heads that maybe they wouldn't
entertain without the humor aspect of it
and so when i write if i write on a
subject whatever the subject might be
i write without thinking oh i have to
make each word funny or i have to make
each sentence funny i write just what
are my thoughts on this subject and then
along the way i find irony and
i find
ridiculous
perceptions and all the things that lead
to stand-up comedy material
we're gonna extract those right and how
much of that like humor and the whip
just occurs to you spontaneously on the
stage
sometimes a lot it depends on the
subject but
it's always a possibility some of the
best lines that i've ever come up with
in my act come up with i come up with on
the spot while i'm just talking about
things right well that should be when
you're like into the subject and and
things are going well with the audience
yeah yeah that's basically how it goes
it's a tricky business yeah it sounds
like an extremely tricky business and
one where the cost of failure is is
humiliation and and and uh emotional
pain
yeah it's the worst yeah yeah there's
not there's not that many things that
are more embarrassing than like trying
to be funny especially if you've put
say a hundred hours into one hour of
preparation which is less than you're
doing and then finding out that you're
just not that amusing
that does more common than that
yeah not good so how many netflix
specials have you done now
uh i've done three
and uh i'm working on my fourth one
right now but overall i've done
nine
different
hours of comedy either a comedy album or
a video special
yeah uh what and you what's it been like
working for netflix
it's great they're very easy oh that's
yeah they they don't
they really don't have any notes they
just let me
you know fortunately i got to them at a
stage in my career where i was already
advanced and i was already a headliner
and i'd already been doing stand-up
comedy for decades so it was it was good
in that sense that i i was well prepared
but they you know they
when we first signed this initial deal
they were they were really just wanting
me to do what i do best right so they
liked it and it's easy
there's no there's really relatively
little input almost none right so
they're they're they're not willing to
mess with success fundamentally
yeah they like what i do so they're just
like go ahead just and they know that my
goal is to do my best i'm not trying to
i mean there are comedians that will
release material just for the money
they'll try to capitalize on their fame
and put something out that's sloppy and
i feel like
for me at least that's that's not an
option and that would taint my legacy
and tape my
my body of work i'm not interested in
doing that
right right yeah well i've seen your
netflix specials and they're pretty damn
funny
thank you that that's that that's that
ver that uh little skit you did on the
kardashians
i was a killer man
thank you that took forever to work out
i figured out a way to make fun of that
guy
god it was it was it was ridiculous you
make an extremely intense
demonic gargoyle
a very good sense of humor
you know so that was killing me i
thought jesus he's not gonna go there is
he oh yeah yeah
oh he's gonna go farther
yeah
it's good to see that kind of like
horrific courage manifest itself on
stage you really like that in a comedian
you know when you see them get going and
i used to see this with sarah silverman
you could see her eyes sort of flash and
she'd think
i shouldn't say that there's no way to
say that then she'd say it you'd think
yeah oh no one should have said that but
man he was deadly
yeah i think out of all the women doing
comedy right now she's probably the best
at that
you know she can come up with pushing
that envelope yeah that's for sure she's
got there's some very dark recesses in
that woman's mind
yeah yeah okay so the netflix thing is
going well do you do you enjoy do you
enjoy doing that
yes
what do you like about it
the danger of it the the difficulty
the challenge that one it's done and
people enjoy it that i'm legitimately
affecting people i love i love that when
people they'll get a chance to sit down
and watch it for an hour and it'll make
them feel better they'll laugh they they
it takes them out of the dreary
dullness of their day or the agony of
whatever they're going through in their
life and they can escape that for an
hour and yeah thank god for comedy man
it's just about it's just in the same
domain as music for necessity
yeah i agree
there are campuses now where there's
like
no sarcasm rules say
oh that's hilarious god can you imagine
i'd i'd last like 15 seconds like
yeah it's like sarcasm considered a
microaggression is that definitely
unless it's real sarcasm in which case
it's a macro aggression
i just keep thinking that in time this
is going to be one of the most
hysterical uh periods of time that
people look back on periods of history
like you know when we look at guys with
powdered wigs and you know preposterous
behavior from the past and we go god
what were they thinking i really think
we're going to do the same thing about
today i think well i hope one of the
most i i think for sure i hope so that
means that we'll be more sane when we're
looking back or at least we'll be
playing in a different way and i'm
pretty much ready for a different form
of insane personally
well i think the insane that you're
getting
is so
it's so pronounced and it's so much more
intense
that
it it's less effective and then the
reaction to it is more popular the the
negative reaction to a lot of this
insane rhetoric and this insane behavior
it's more popular now to understand how
ridiculous some of these people are you
know when you see like what antifa is
doing in portland blocking traffic and
you know
telling people where to go and what to
do and then beating people up that don't
comply
and saying that you're a white
supremacist if you don't listen to them
and like this this all this stuff is so
ridiculous it's so over the top and they
keep feeding on themselves they keep
attacking people that are not
progressive enough they keep
literally eating their own and it it for
the from the outside from the
perspective of people that don't share
their ideology it looks more and more
ridiculous and that makes them more and
more frenzied and it ramps it all up and
i think it's ultimately going to crash
it's just like what kind of damage is it
gonna do to the landscape as it's
crashing right right well that's that's
the thing that you know hopefully can be
mitigated so that the landing isn't too
hard
so i thought look every time we've
talked we've talked a lot about me and
like i'm quite sick of talking about me
actually and probably have been for like
a year
or maybe even longer
so i thought that it would be really
good to talk about you and i'm curious
about you because you're such a strange
character and so um
you know in the in the most interesting
of ways and so i thought i'd like start
at the beginning so i don't know that
much about you so
um
where'd you grow up
well i grew up in a lot of places i was
born in new jersey
i lived there until i was seven
my mother uh split up from my dad and
married my stepdad
we moved to california we lived in san
francisco from age 7 to 11. then i lived
in florida he was going to the
university of florida at gainesville
lived there from age 11 to right around
then we moved to boston and i lived in
boston for
the next
i guess the next 10 years and that's
really where i grew up i grew up
basically when i when i think of where i
come from i think of boston it's also
the place where i started doing stand-up
comedy which means a lot to me and it's
also where i started fighting so i
started doing martial arts but all the
significant things that happened in my
life happened in boston in my
developmental period and so you moved to
boston when you were how old
13. i see yeah right right and then you
were there for how many years
11 years oh yeah so that's a long time
yeah where do you live in boston
newton newton upper falls it's a suburb
of boston yeah
yeah nice new england day
yeah i love it out there yeah you know
the people have a great sense of humor
it's uh like toronto in a way that you
have to deal with that wicked winter and
i think that develops character in
people i think it was funny but when i
moved to boston
because i well i lived in alberta and
then montreal and montreal is
bloody horrible in the winter and
alberta's even worse and so i was i'd go
down to boston and
i went down there to interview first and
it was february and like it was spring
as far as i was concerned i didn't even
have a coat on and then when we lived
there for years you know it was so funny
we lived in this old house by a park and
we get those nor'easters blow in you
know with the hurricane level winds and
it bloody well snow three and a half
feet and i'd be thinking in my canadian
way that jesus i better not go inside
because i'll just freeze to death the
second i step outside but i'd go outside
it was like
well it was 34 degrees or some damn
thing it's like i was expecting -40 you
know just horrible so my boston winters
never
i mean apart from the snow which was you
know deadly significant they never
really struck me as winter they sort of
struck me as well this is the sort of
winter that you'd like to have if you
wanted a like a showy winter that people
could be pleased with rather than one
that just sort of killed you
yeah yeah canadians are on another level
when it comes to winter i have some
pretty good friends that live in alberta
and uh when i whenever i go up there
it's like whoa
yeah
where do you go um
they're uh outside of edmonton they're
about uh two and a half hours north of
edmonton
where
uh i don't know the name of their town
it's where i go bear hunting
um
that's uh yeah because barry you know
you might one thing you notice about
bear is they have fur
see
live there
they don't have fur so they actually
live there yeah two and a half hours
north of edmonton in the winter yeah
yeah you see you go outside yeah you go
outside in the wrong day and you're out
there too long then you die
so yeah or you run into a grizzly which
is awesome
that yes there's also that those those
those are those are nothing to contend
those are nothing to take lightly man
when we used to go camping especially in
british columbia grizzly bears were
always a concern because like a black
bear if it chases you
and first of all it's only about third
the size of a grizzly bear and it's
still pretty big like it's a black bear
you know it's not it's not like a house
cat and if those things chase you and
you and you play dead they'll usually
leave you alone but if you grizzly
chases you and you play dead then it
eats you and so and then of course if
you fight back well it also eats you it
just maybe you get a a blow or two in
and probably not so
yeah that was one of the terrorists
more people are uh preyed upon by black
bears when a black bear attacks you it's
usually because it's trying to eat you
when a grizzly bear attacks people it's
usually either mistake or it was it was
scared or it's really hungry
yeah the black bears tend to be like
that too a lot of them are old if they
attack you yeah yeah they're getting
they're getting so they can't catch a
real animal so they're they'll settle
for like a uh you know as an arctic
monkey with no fat
so
yeah they get desperate yeah so okay so
new jersey what do you remember about
new jersey
uh
boy that's where i went to catholic
school which was uh a horror in and of
itself and uh it's you know where my
relatives lived and i just remember the
the ethnic ethnic italian environment
and what that was like you know with
what it was like being around my
relatives around there very
sopranos-like if you ever watch the tv
show oh yeah that's that's really
representative of a lot of new jersey
you know i don't remember too much other
than that though and i was pretty little
when we left don't have relatives out
there
um i have one uncle well two uncles that
still live there do you ever see them
i haven't seen them in years
okay so new jersey mostly positive
memories do you think or just it's just
i mean seven and below that's pretty
young so
well it was tumultuous time period for
me my parents
were uh always fighting and it just
wasn't a good time so when we escaped
new jersey it was a relief and that was
also when your mom split up from your
dad
yeah and do you do do you stu are you in
contact with your dad
no i haven't spoken him since i was
seven years old
is he still alive
he's still alive and his name's joe
rogan which is even crazier
huh
so you ever think about him
no
no not really no no it's a long time ago
well that's
huh
well and do you remember what he was
like to you
he was nice to me
he just wasn't very nice to my mother so
they had a very bad relationship
right
okay so you leave new jersey and you go
to california
yeah where did you live there
we lived in san francisco
and uh that was an interesting time for
me because
it was during the vietnam war
and it was sort of the height of the
hippie movement right my stepdad was a
hippie my father was a police officer in
new jersey
oh yeah so i went from being around a
cop who was a pretty brutal guy
to being around a long-haired hippie it
was all about peace and love and he was
an architecture student you know it was
a completely different sort of vibe
yeah sounds like a completely different
sort of vibe
yeah talking around a lot of gay folks
yeah around a lot of hippies a lot of
pot smokers a lot of real open-minded
thinkers and weirdos around haight
ashbury and and that that sort of area
we live near lombard street
it was real classic san francisco in the
70s
70s so yeah so yeah let's see so you
would have been
you said seven
how
so when it was like 74 seven probably 74
because i was uh seven years old right
born 67
yeah so you're five years i see you're
five years younger than me so that that
places you there so yeah it was still
pretty hippie central
yeah it was pretty it was pretty
interesting
um and then i went from there to florida
which is like a total polar opposite
you know that was uh the first time i'd
ever heard anybody say the n-word was in
florida and i didn't know what it meant
i had to ask my mother my mother got
upset at me but she thought i knew what
it meant i was just playing games i was
like i don't know what it means like
tell me what it means she said it's a
bad word for black people and i was like
wow
really
okay
because i was hearing it all the time
i i never heard it in san francisco i
literally didn't hear it until i was 13
years old or excuse me 11 years old
and so yeah so where did you move to vue
in florida
we moved to gainesville
which is where the university of florida
was uh where my stepdad was going um to
get a
he was go he's studying architecture and
then we eventually moved to boston so he
could go to the boston architectural
center that's why we wound up moving
there and is your mom
and as your mom and your step-dad still
together yep still together and do you
see them
all the time yeah they have a great
relationship it's really completely
different they've been together forever
they they just they get along fantastic
and in many ways that sort of modeled my
expectations for a real relationship you
know like i saw the worst and then i saw
a really great one and i'm like okay i
want that you know
yeah that's a good choice that's that's
that shows some wisdom on your part
picking the second one rather than the
first one let's say
yeah
yeah yeah has that worked out have you
had good relationships
oh yeah yeah i mean my wife's awesome
yeah you've been married for how long
almost 10 years 10 years and you have
two girls or three
i have three girls three girls right
yeah two young ones and one adult one
right i remember on the special that i
was referring to that you were bemoaning
the fact that you were absolutely
saturated in a feminine environment
yeah yeah it's interesting man it's
interesting but i think it balances me
out i think ultimately it's probably
good for me yeah you think it's
interesting now you wait till they hit
teenagehood
yeah then it'll be interesting all right
yeah for sure
yeah i actually enjoyed having teenagers
you know weirdly enough i mean we had a
good rule in our house with our kids
brought their friends over to our house
a lot
um
and it was funny because when they first
came over when my teenagers friends came
over they were always afraid of me
but after about a month being there you
know like getting to know the place a
bit not staying there all the time
obviously but getting a bit familiar
with it they ended up being a lot more
afraid of my wife
so that was quite funny but she's you
know she just looked like but she
doesn't look that dangerous on first
impressions
and she's kind of soft-spoken but uh
she's very
unforgiving that might be one way of
putting it
and then
we had a pretty good rule in our house
with the teenage kids which is was it's
a good one to know which was look we're
really happy you're here you know
but if you do something really stupid
and we never ever have to see you again
that would actually be okay with us
that's a good rule it's a good rule they
also knew they meant it and so the kids
could have their friends over you know
they could have a reasonable they could
have a reasonable amount of fun or maybe
even a slightly unreasonable amount of
fun but they couldn't have an
overwhelmingly unreasonable amount of
fun
so a great way to put it overwhelmingly
unreasonable amount of fun is a great
way to put it yeah that was too much too
much we had a good drug policy too i
think
which was that girl
i think it went well the rule was um
look i know perfectly well you're going
to experiment they were going to an art
school you know it's like
i think i think that one of the majors
was like pot smoking and another was
experimentation like there was just no
way they weren't gonna experiment and my
rule was um
i better not be able to tell because
you're being too much of a fool so if
you're gonna pyramid
you better handle it because otherwise
you're pathetic
and
that seemed to be pretty good well
that's you know because i thought i
already thought it through you know
because there's a there's a literature
on uh
experimentation among adolescents both
criminal experimentation you know
delinquency minor delinquency and that
sort of thing and drug use and you get
pathology at both ends the ones who are
you know smoking pot every day and
taking drugs on a regular basis
their outcomes not so good but the ones
who abstain completely and never
experiment their outcome is also not so
good they tend to be on the dependent
anxious end of the distribution and so
you know you want your kids to
well
play with the rules a little bit but
then i thought well what so okay you got
to play with the rules a little bit what
are the rules about playing with the
rules and one should be try not to be a
bigger fool than necessary
that's a good one
so you're not compromising yourself in
the present but the biggest the biggest
issue i think really and i think this is
the fundamental rule for experimentation
with adolescents is you don't get to
screw up your future
right yes that's that's the killer
well what i worry about more than
anything is opioids
um i i worry about those uh because
people are dying from them yeah you know
no one's dying from pot it's very rare
that anybody
is doing something so stupid that they
put their life in danger from pot or
mushrooms
i'm worried about the ones that kill you
you know i mean i worry about pills more
than anything
that my children might possibly face
especially when i consider the fact that
these
opiate manufacturers these opioid
manufacturers they keep making these
damn things stronger and i don't
understand i mean it's not like
oxycontin wasn't strong enough as it is
but now they have fentanyl and now
they're coming up with things that are
stronger than fentanyl it's disgusting
yeah well weird arms really say because
i mean this is something that's really
an unexpected consequence of the of the
illegalization of drugs is that
now we've generated all these chemists
who are really good at making tiny
variations on every psychoactive
substance known and now instead of like
addictive substances you can get
yourself into serious trouble with
there's 300
yeah that doesn't seem to be a big plus
no it doesn't it's it's it's disturbing
and it's disgusting and you know they're
finally starting to bring some of these
guys to justice and they're arresting
some of these people and bringing them
to court
uh some of these manufacturers but
they've been pushing this stuff down
people's throats for years and
supervising doctors to subscribe them
and
when my daughter was sick um
when she was a kid
she was in extreme
it's got to be agony is the right word
you know for like two years about that
because she was walking around on two
broken legs you know her story a little
bit
and uh
the physician at sick kids which which
was the person who was dealing with her
arthritis would only prescribe her
basically uh you know anderson you know
minor league over-the-counter
painkillers which was like
trying to kill a grizzly bear with a fly
swatter it really
wasn't right the right tool for the job
we found a family doctor who had enough
courage to prescribe her oxycontin
that was no joke you know because for
the first couple of weeks she was on
oxycontin it was really
odd and rough because it was like she
was drunk and so that was
well that was weird socially to say the
least
and also rather frightening but it did
control her pain
and we actually had them mix oxycontin
with uh ritalin
which is a strange combination but a
good one to know about because
oxycontin sedates and ritalin stimulates
but the combination of the two are
synergistic so they can really control
pain
and so her pain was controlled enough so
that it didn't drive her insane over
about a two-year period and then once
she got her operations and had her had
her legs fixed
she went off the opiates and she went
through the whole withdrawal stick you
know she had like night sweats and she
had ants crawling under her skin and
like it was pretty brutal although she
she stopped cold turkey and never tried
them again she hated them she said they
just made her feel dead and it's funny a
lot of people you know a lot you hear
the horror stories that you know if you
try opiates once you're pretty much
screwed because they're so wonderful but
lots of people don't like them but there
is a sizable minority of people you know
who
really like them and and then there is
the danger that you described of
overdose and that's you know that's
that's a frightening thing hopefully
your kids smart enough to stay mostly
away from pills
yeah hopefully what are you know you got
to worry about the influence of their
friends and peer pressure
yeah yeah definitely well the terrible
thing about teenagers you know is that
everybody always says well why do you
succumb to peer pressure when you're a
teenager and the answer is well that's
why you're a teenager
you know you're getting away from your
family
and you're even getting away from your
like elementary school best friend and
you're starting to join the broader
social group
and your job is to fit in
like not to fit in so much that there's
nothing left of you you know but your
job is to fit into the tribe to the
group and to learn how to do that and of
course the downside is well you're
susceptible to peer pressure but
there's it's hard to distinguish that
from actually being properly socialized
you know the two things are very tightly
aligned
all right so so you were in florida and
you learned you learned some words that
that you didn't know and what was
florida like for you you were there only
for a couple of years
yeah florida is a strange place i mean i
still have a love-hate relationship with
florida it's the land of the lost it's
where people go to escape wherever
they're from
um billy corgan
who's uh
billy corbin who's a
documentary director he directed cocaine
cowboys and a bunch of other great
documentaries
he he lives down in florida and every
time he and i talk we just talk about
how ridiculous florida is
and it's
this place where people go to escape
they go to escape from the brutal cold
of the northeast winter or they go oh
jesus
my phone is
yeah my phone is telling me that i'm
running out of batteries
i'm going to have to switch headsets and
plug this in but it'll only take a
second yeah that should be fine but uh
i just think that florida is just like a
uniquely stupid place
it's a weird place you know it's yeah
it's it's one of the things that's
really struck me about the united states
that's really different than canada for
what that's worth it's not like
americans really care why the united
states is different than canada apart
from the fact that it isn't like
freezing cold six months of the years
there's a there's a lot of the us it's
like a movie set
you know so much of it is like it's
manufactured to look like something else
and florida is really like that
yeah and it
it's it's a very strange place to visit
because everything is not in the old
towns but the beach towns are like that
a lot that there's so there's some
genuine old florida but most of it is
it's manufactured fake utopia for
exactly the sort of people that you're
describing
you know that's not unbearable or
anything i mean the weather's nice and
the beach is nice and you know there's
worse places to live but
there's something about it that's
like a i don't know it's it's like a
ah that's a real it's not this well
obviously it's like a resort but resorts
have that sort of fake
utopian element to them that
is i don't know what it's like exactly
kind of like a child fantasy or an
adolescent fantasy something like that
you know it's what you think you want
if you don't yeah i heard
i always say that if you want to starve
to death open up a bookstore in miami
[Music]
[Laughter]
right like legitimately there's there's
no reading going on down there
it's just a strange place where people
go to party and
it's just it's weird
right now i have to warn you that there
is a beam of light shooting directly out
of your head oh right here yeah it's
very impressive and and move this around
there we go
yeah that's probably better because you
know i had to
plug in
because uh the power was dying on my
phone i guess this video stuff
sucks a lot of power i guess i guess so
i guess so i mean i
the didn't things shooting out of your
head but you never know you don't want
to get any rumors on the internet
i don't know how easy that is
well yeah you amongst all people know
how easy that is hey
hey i haven't been in this scandal for a
whole a whole week
well this podcast is still young
yeah fair enough fair enough we might be
able to cover something that'll cause
trouble
you are
at all the people that i'm friends with
you are probably the most misrepresented
friend that i have
and uh i defend you quite often and i i
i don't get where people are coming from
with you i don't understand their
inability to listen to your words and
instead they try to generalize and
formulate these distorted
distorted descriptions of who you are
and what you stand for and it's very
strange to me and i don't know
i mean i kind of do know that you're
challenging a lot of people's beliefs
and the way they
you know they've they've structured
these beliefs but it's very frustrating
to me and i'm sure it must be way more
frustrating for you
it's kind of it's kind of on
it's surreal to me because
i was talking with my kids about this
the other day
you know
the way people think i am especially if
they read you know the hit pieces that
the journalists have written and maybe
even watch me in those interactions you
know they think i'm provocative and they
think i like combat and conflict and
you know um
and i don't i'm not combat eventually
and i really don't like conflict that
much um i go out of my way quite a bit
to avoid it
and you know
i'm misogynist except that almost the
all the people i've ever worked with in
my whole life have been women and i've
been in a women-dominated field
and
like
i never thought of myself as right wing
that's for sure i mean i mean maybe now
that the far left has gone completely
off the deep end it's like well
maybe i'd be classified as a
conservative but that's mostly because
as a social scientist i learned that you
shouldn't conduct large-scale
experiments on huge swaths of the
population and assume that your stupid
idea is going to work out correctly
because it won't
you can't even get people to behave
properly in a lab for like half an hour
so how you think you're going to get a
whole society to do what you want
you know as a consequence of passing a
piece of legislation is beyond me but
yeah it's it's and here's something else
that's weird you know like if you read
the newspapers
on this this new you knew i got
disinvited from cambridge cambridge
divinity school i mean what what a thing
to be disinvited from a divinity school
christ you have to be satan himself to
get disinvited from a divinity school
and
you know
well it's so
crazy you know and i just wanted to go
down there and learn some more about the
biblical stories the exodus stories that
was the idea
and
then to get disinvited to have that be a
whole big scandal it was just like
what the hell man it's it's
it's quite the crazy situation and then
so you read about all this and and you
see this online and you think god his
life must just be hell
because of all the controversy but then
when i go out in the streets
or to my lectures or anywhere it's
completely different it's unbelievably
different like so now if i walked it
walk down the street i mean when you
walk down the street you must just get
out you just must get uh
identified all the time
but yeah if you go out in an hour how
many people will come up to you
depends where i go
but uh if i'm in hollywood it's pretty
pretty crazy if i go around young people
if you see men and they have shaved
heads and tattoos it gets nuts
those are my people how muscular men
so yeah so if i go out you know and i'm
walking down the street and it doesn't
really matter where usually i get
approached five or six times in an hour
by people and
you know they're always very polite and
they're very apologetic and they they
are happy about something they've read
or listened to or whatever or often they
talk about our podcast that's pretty
damn common that was common throughout
europe
as well
and you know they tell me about some
dark part of their life and how they're
doing much better and you know how their
friends have been watching my videos and
they're feeling better about it so it's
just
ridiculously positive just all the time
and then when i go to my lectures
it's the same thing
it's like crazily positive so you know
we've had
350 000 people at the lectures so far
and there hasn't been one
negative occurrence we had one heckler
once who was rapidly escorted from the
building and he knew he was going to get
escorted so he was kind of a cooperative
heckler but like no one's coming there
with any
thing negative on their mind they're
there to listen to a psychological
lecture to have a deep discussion and to
try to get their act together and the
goddamn journalists they just don't seem
to be able to fathom that like they've
got this false cynicism or maybe real
cynicism that makes it absolutely
impossible for them to believe that
you know tens of thousands of people
could actually be
serious about improving their life and
that i could be having events that were
basically 100 percent positive and so
online i'm a bloody monster you know i'm
a misogynistic racist in the transphobe
and uh what else am i
i'm a homophobe and uh oh a nazi lots of
times and sometimes a jewish shill and
um
well there's a bunch of other things too
oh you disturbed me
excuse me what disturbed me about you is
when they pulled your books out of new
zealand
when a new zealand bookstore decided to
pull your books because of the christ
church massacre like what does a book on
self improvement
and taking responsibility what does that
have to do with a horrific mass murder i
mean the idea that they can connected
those two together and that they decided
that in some way or shape your
words of encouragement and recognizing
the importance of discipline and of
taking responsibility and self-reliance
that those things your your book
somehow or another had something to do
with someone doing something as awful as
what happened at christchurch it's it's
so distorted and that's like the perfect
example that i cite when i say like
think about the fact that this guy's
book was removed
and right after something had taken
place that had literally nothing to do
with anything you've ever said ever
yeah well
they kind of got their comeuppance in
some ways because people started to
point out that they were still carrying
mein kampf
and so that turned out to be a problem
and then they were also carrying a book
that
showed you how to turn a semi-automatic
into a fully automatic
and so you know you've got to be careful
when you go after someone for their sins
that you don't have a few sins of your
own like lying around where people can
you know sort of observe them anyways
they did reverse that decision but
but uh that's good yeah yeah that was
good but it is it's very weird it's it's
it's it's it's a and i'm going to the uk
here right away now we're talking about
me and we weren't supposed to be but i'm
going to the uk right away because the
paperback is launching there and so i'm
going to be talking to journalists and
talking to uk journalists man that's
like jumping into a a tub of well not
full-grown crocodiles but you know like
five-footers anyways
so what you're trying to say is
yeah they're pretty snappy
so yeah i'm i've got some trepidation
about that
but so it's a funny it's a funny life to
it's a very peculiar life to be involved
in and i'm not exactly ever sure what to
make of it on a day-to-day basis but it
does give you what's the most peculiar
so that's what's most peculiar for you
is that you were not famous for most of
your adult life and then over the last
four years you've been catapulted and
become one of the most famous if not the
most famous psychologist on the planet
earth yes it's very
disconcerting it's hard to get it it's
actually rather hard to adjust to that
i mean maybe it's a function of age i
found you know when when i was younger
and i i used to move from place to place
take me about a year to adapt but i also
noticed that as i got older
every time i moved it took me longer to
adapt by the time you're 56 you know if
you know someone for 10 years it's like
you feel like you're just starting to
get to know them a bit
you know when you're 17 you have a
roommate for six months and it's like
your best friends for the rest of your
life
so it is a very difficult thing to adapt
to i i can't
i can't i can't really wrap my mind
around it and it i guess it's also
partly because it's true no matter where
i go like i went to slovenia you know
and it's
everybody speaks english in slovenia by
the way and you are a big hit in
slovenia i don't know if you know this
but i i it looks to me like the podcast
youtube world has even more impact in
places where the press is not very
reliable
like everybody knew about our everybody
knew about our interviews and our
podcasts and so i was stopped in
slovenia constantly which is that was a
real shock too
so but if again so the shock is and this
is the weird thing about youtube and
about podcasts is that it's not
it's just not one country or two
countries it's like every damn country
and so
it's
but i'm i'm really fortunate really
fortunate because like i said all the
public encounters i have are
are extremely positive they're hard to
cope with though you know in some sense
because people are always they always
tell me a serious story
you know they say
i was in some sort of hell of some sort
six months ago too much drugs or alcohol
or bad relationship or not getting along
with my family or underemployed or
nihilistic or depressed whatever you
know like whatever little corner of hell
they have to occupy it they've
been practicing something like maybe
developing a vision for their life or
trying to live a more meaningful life or
taking more responsibility or or like
really making an effort to pull their
families together um
and to enter to advance at work
regardless of what their job is and
and it's working and so they're always
like shell-shocked that is working and
thrilled to death but it's so strange to
have these intense
20-second 30-second conversations with
people about really deep elements of
their life and then you know
it's it's a shock and then you walk
along the street and it's a normal day
and then someone else comes up and does
the same thing it's like i don't know
what to do with it emotionally it's it's
because maybe you know someone might
tell you that
i don't know maybe they tell you that
something if you've been helping them
maybe they tell you that once a year
once every five years or something but
to have it happen all the time is i
don't know it i think it fills me with a
kind of sorrow like i'm really happy
that it's happening and everything but
there's still something about it that's
deeply
and and and
deeply moving and difficult to adjust to
so and the sorrow because so many people
are struggling out there and that you're
encountering all these folks well the
sorrow is that there's so many people
struggling out there
and
they don't have this sort of they they
have so little support that
my lectures and podcasts in the book
were
what was necessary to help them
straighten themselves out it's like you
know you just can't imagine how many
people out there haven't heard an
encouraging word
you know it's like their home on the
what's the old song and home on the
range
yeah that's where you don't hear a
discouraging word well these people have
never heard an encouraging word and
that's it's sad to see how common that
is and how little
it takes to re turn that around and it's
so fun out in the lectures because you
know a lot of the people in my lectures
are crack they're the same people you
were talking about that stop you in
hollywood you know they're kind of rough
working class guys that'd be about 30 of
my audience i would think you know and
they're not the sort of people that you
would stereotypically presume would come
to an hour and a half lecture on you
know philosophy and psychology but man
they're listening they're listening like
mad and it's so
fun and interesting to watch them think
it through and to and to take this
seriously and you know they come up
afterwards and they say you know i've
been watching your lectures and i'm a
much better husband or i'm a much better
father and sometimes they have their
girlfriend or wife with them and she
says the same thing and you know
it's really nice man
it's really something yeah
well you really are making a giant
impact and it's only understandable that
it would be difficult for you to wrap
your head around
what this is and
it's it's not something that very few
human beings ever get to experience a
very very very tiny percentage of our
population
uh worldwide is ever put into position
like you're put into so
let's look at your position i mean i
asked you this one time so
you
you last time we talked i think you were
getting something
100 million downloads a month on your
podcast what are your figures if you
didn't if you don't mind
double that jesus christ that's just
unbelievable with youtube
with the youtube and all the youtube
clips and it's it's it's actually
probably more than that
it's nuts i it's gotten to the point
where
i try to pay as little attention to the
numbers as possible
and just concentrate on doing the show
because i think if i pay attention to it
too much
excuse me i think if i pay attention to
it too much i might lose my mind i mean
it's just it's untenable it's just the
sheer volume of human beings when you if
you if you were ever on a stage and you
were looking out at 300 million people
what would that look like
i mean it's not 300 million people
because it's 300 million downloads in a
month but the the real
number of human beings you're
interacting with i mean i don't know
what that is
50 million people i don't know how many
actual million people are listening to
the show or watching the show on a
regular basis but it's an unmanageable
number in terms of like reading comments
or trying to pay attention to what they
want or what they don't want
it's uh it's very strange
yes it's a very weird it's very weird
position to be and there's no doubt and
the strange thing is too is that well
we've talked about this before too
like this is early days right i mean
this has only been happening for about
how long have you been doing your
youtube videos
the youtube videos are only a few years
so i think it's only three or four years
the podcast will be 10 years in december
right okay so 10 years that's starting
to become a decent chunk of life but
three or four years that's still new
and yeah i mean the podcast market and
the youtube market are still they're
brand new technologies fundamentally
yeah fundamentally and now you're seeing
corporations trying to capitalize on it
and you know i've started to get these
very bizarre offers to make my podcast
exclusive on this platform or that
platform
and you know these these companies are
they're throwing crazy amounts of money
around that podcast
like
networks hundreds of millions of dollars
to buy podcast networks so it's it's
it's becoming very very strange because
what was a joke five or six years ago
literally why are you wasting your time
doing a podcast i used to hear that all
the time now it's how did you do this
how did you make this podcast so popular
and you get a totally different question
yeah well absolutely well it's so
strange because
so many people have
nobody realized that there was a
an audience for on-demand audio and you
see the same thing
not only that
but not just on-demand audio but
long-form conversations yeah one of the
i mean even my friend ari who's one of
my best friends would always tell me you
got to edit your shows nobody wants to
listen to anything that's three hours
long so i'd say well then they don't
have to listen
and he's like uh you like you're you're
doing yourself a disservice and i'm like
i don't think i am
like why not if someone only has an hour
then listen to it for an hour like
you're not gonna i mean you might miss
out some information but it's not gonna
change your life like do whatever you
wanna do but i like talking to people
for long periods of time because
i think you really only get cooking
after like the first half hour or 40
minutes that's when you get comfortable
you sort of get a into a groove of
communication
you know figuring out this person's
rhythm and thought processes and
it you you and then as you expand on
these ideas and you share information
back and forth with each other after an
hour an hour and a half two hours that's
when things really start getting deep
and oftentimes the last hour of a
three-hour podcast is the best hour
yeah well that intuition was certainly
right and revolutionary you never know
when you come up with a revolutionary
idea
you know yeah i mean part of my
revolutionary idea is just me being
stubborn
just like i didn't care i wasn't doing
it for money so the only reason why i
was doing it was because i enjoyed
talking to people like you or many of my
other guests i i want to talk to it's a
very rare opportunity where i would get
a chance to sit down with someone like
you with no distractions no other people
in the room no cell phones and just talk
for three hours that's so unusual in our
world and our constantly distracted
world and i think i've gotten gotten a
fantastic education because of that i
mean it's really enlightened me on so
many different subjects and expanded my
understanding of people in general and
conspiracy theories i mean man you're up
on those
let's get some of those too yeah so
that's it's important to be up on the
conspiracy theories just to keep track
of the damn things well you got to know
what people think of you you know i've
been lately i'm a zionist shill this is
the
most recent one i didn't know it was a
zionist shield oh yeah you're zarnis
chill yeah i'm a white supremacist too
depending on who you ask yeah yeah well
i've got those two things as well so and
that and that's like it's real
interesting to be able to juggle both of
those identities it's like yeah good
luck with that so one day white
supremacist the next it's sort of like a
gender fluid except on the political
spectrum yeah that's a good way to look
at it yeah everyone why do you have to
be conservative or democrat you know
sometimes you're one and sometimes the
other it depends on the day and there's
no reason yeah extend that like all the
way out to the edges
you know yeah gender fluid is my
favorite that's my favorite thing that's
going on right now where someone could
be like a woman for a few hours and then
be a man for the next six you know i
respect back
i read although i don't know if this is
true
but i but i read it several places and i
actually looked i read that the
olympic committee is going to let trans
people compete in the olympics in the
next competition
i'm not surprised because the olympic
the ioc the olympic committee is uh
incredibly corrupt and uh i think what
they do first of all is disgraceful uh
they make billions of dollars the
athletes make zero i think it's
disgusting i think everything about what
they do is corrupt and the idea that
they're there for fair and and
and
pure competition is nonsense they're
there to make shitloads of money and
that's what they're good at and what
they're good at doing is putting on
these gigantic events where they profit
in in spectacular and staggering ways
and the athletes dedicate their entire
life to these moments and they literally
make nothing and then after that if
they're lucky
if they're very famous and popular they
can eke out a living with uh
endorsements right or you know for the
rare person like michael phelps or
someone like that who's just a true
outlier they can actually get wealthy
from it but it's very very rare
most of those athletes will be in severe
debt most of those athletes either have
to get sponsored or they have to find
someone who is willing to
uh share the burden and and help them
achieve their goals but
without some sort of altruistic uh
benefactor who's got millions of dollars
to pour into their camp i mean it's just
it's disgusting they're professional
athletes i mean that's what they do with
their entire life if you want to win a
gold medal in the olympics in gymnastics
you can't have a side job you can't be
working eight hours a day no you have to
be a professional athlete and the
olympic committee knows this and
and if you've ever paid attention to how
they've let people get away with
cheating i mean there's a fantastic
documentary out right now um by brian
fogle called icarus and it's all about
the sochi olympics and how russia
cheated in the sochi olympics and the
ioc
barely punished them they they punished
a few people and how the ioc and the
world anti-doping agency all
they have people from each
they have from each organization they
share like they go back and forth they
work for one and they work for the other
and they're totally in conflict it's a
total conflict of interest and it's a
it's a dirty business so if the tide of
political uh
perception is that it's a good
progressive thing to have trans women
competing in the ufc or not i shouldn't
say the ufc that'll never happen but
trans women competing in the olympics
and that this was uh what everybody
wanted they would just do it they would
do it regardless of whether or not it's
fair regardless of whether or not it
made sense and they would do it just to
get more eyes on the show just to get
more money and that's that's what
they're there for that's what they're
good at fascinating to see how all that
plays out because it's so absurd i was
looking i looked up some stats the other
day because i was curious you know it's
like okay
i know that all the differences between
men and women are socially constructed
but nonetheless i went looked up the
biological comparison of strength you
know and the typical woman has 30
percent of the upper body strength of
the typical man and about 55 to the
lower body strength now that's like
that's a big difference man that makes
the average man three times as strong in
the upper body jesus that gives you an
advantage that's just well it's criminal
so well it is but the question is how
much do you lose from the conversion
how much did you lose from estrogen you
lose some but if a woman say look if you
have an athlete who's a woman who's 32
years old and it turns out that she's
been taking steroids her entire adult
life so she's been taking steroids for
12 years every day and then decides to
stop taking them right before the
olympics wouldn't everybody agree that
she has a massive advantage wouldn't
everybody agree that most likely her
tendon strength her muscle strength her
bone structure all of that has been
completely altered by taking
performance-enhancing drugs we would all
agree to that well guess what that's
what you're doing if you're a man for 30
years and then you decide to transition
and become a woman for two even if
you're taking estrogen even if you go
through this thing i don't understand is
apart from the
obvious unfairness of that
uh what what i struggle with
understanding is the
triumphalism of the
victors
it's like they they enter these contests
and then they win
and then they celebrate their victory as
if it's a genuine victory despite the
fact right wiped out these women who've
been
working mostly within the rules for like
you know
maybe not decades but certainly many
many years in succession and they just
blow them away especially in like
strength contests and then they they
actually treat that like they won and
then they also claim it as a moral
victory you know and for me that that's
just
that i the only the only thing i see in
that is a narcissism that's so deep that
it's almost unfathomable it's like how
can you take pride in that sort of
victory unless you don't see
who it is that you're defeating
i don't get it
well
it it shows how pathological
this whole thing really is when you're
when you're dealing with the idea that
you can turn
a person into someone of the opposite
gender not just recognize them as being
a woman and treat them as a woman and
allow them to use whatever name they
would like i'm all for that but it's
that you are going to say no this is a
woman and she should be able to compete
with women including in combat sports
rugby there's a male to female
trans athlete in that plays rugby in
australia that's 240 pounds
and just smashing women and i don't
think there's any real standards that
are universal in terms of like what do
you have to go through in terms of your
conversion therapy and like what what
about size differences when you're
dealing with uh a high impact sport no
because that's a political minefield
like the right the radical end of it is
well you're the gender that you say you
are and the medical conversion is
irrelevant and i don't know how that
translates into the sports world but my
sense is that if the same thing happens
in the sports world that's happened in
the political world that it will be
basically
indistinguishable from whim it's like
well now i'm a woman
just like i had a guy on my podcast
recently and this this came up and it
was a big argument and he his
essentially his stance was
he is all for inclusiveness and he wants
uh he he would like to move towards a
world where trans athletes can compete
and they're included and they can
compete as women and i was trying to
explain the the benefits
of
being a male the physical benefits of
being a male and competing against women
and you know he just didn't want to hear
it it was just in denial of it it was it
was
it was going against these preconceived
notions that he had and that this and
the ideology there's a part of
progressive ideology that is you're
supposed to look at a trans woman as
every bit a woman yeah well that's
because they're supposed to accept the
doctrine that all
differences between men and women are
socially constructed which is of course
and a doctrine that's
i think nonsense it's delusional
nonsense it's yes and it's delusional
for some even deeper reason that's even
harder to fathom and i don't know what
it is yeah it is hard to fathom i don't
i don't understand the root of it i
really don't i even when i talk to
people who
subscribe to these notions i don't
understand the logic i don't understand
where's where's the breakdown in their
perception of the world where they don't
see
and another thing that we got into
now saying another thing that we got
into was
children
transitioning
and then he was informed the form i keep
hearing this this is something i keep
hearing that's driving me mad
that hormone blockers
that these puberty blockers are
reversible they keep saying that they're
like they're harmless they're reversible
if the child changes their mind they
could always just get off the ball and
the results are reversible that's not
true you're affecting the development of
a child if you're using these hormone
blockers you are changing the way the
child is going to develop because
they're not going to have testosterone
the way a normal boy would if they're
transitioning from male to female if
you're doing this to a six-year-old kid
the the the notion that this is
completely reversible is completely
disingenuous because that child is not
going to go through the same
developmental period physically as they
would if they had access to testosterone
they're just not it's just not true it's
not true if you talk to medical doctors
it's not true if you talk to a biologist
it's it's just not true and it's
something that they use to try to
justify the in air quotes harmlessness
of this particular type of therapy that
they're encouraging and it's just
it's just to say that there's nothing
wrong with being trans and i don't think
there is anything wrong with being trans
but i think there is something wrong
with making decisions for a child or
allowing a child to make decisions that
will
massively impact them for the rest of
their life and to make that decision
when you're six like i could only
imagine if i was a person who had gone
through that and then having this
conversation with my parents going why
the [ __ ] did you let me make that
decision well it's gonna be really
interesting to see that play itself out
in the courts in about 12 years
oh it's going to be ugly it's going to
be ugly and it's going to be ugly man
because oh yeah
you don't let go you don't want to let
your six-year-old get a tattoo
right exactly i mean and a tattoo is
fairly reversible the whole thing about
it is nonsense and it's it's
this
whole progressive ideology that they're
subscribing to there's a doctrine like
you have to there's all these different
things that you have to subscribe to if
you want to accept that
ideology this is one of them this is one
of them
yeah yeah yeah
trans children you can't you can't say
yeah that is problematic you can't
you're not allowed to say that you can't
even entertain the notion that this
could be a particularly egregious
offense
on a child if they decide that that was
a bad idea
if the primary idea is that
our society is an oppressive patriarchy
and i think that's like number one idea
then anything that touches on that in
any way immediately becomes untouchable
and so in order for the adults to make
the decision then you have to believe in
authority because the adults have the
authority and if you're going to believe
that the adults have the authority then
you have to believe that hierarchy has
some value and then that tangles you up
with your insistence that you know
hierarchy is definitely
oppressive and and the especially the
western form of hierarchy and so i think
that central axiom is so vital that
anything that gets near it gets twisted
and bent like it's too close to a
gravitational field and and the logic is
irrelevant because that fundamental
central issue has to be uh supported at
all costs
well this is one of the conundrums of
our conversation one of the whether we
came to this one point where i said
now if a child identifies as a girl
i said why not just let them be a girl
why do you have to [ __ ] with their
hormones why do you have to
associate with structure
yeah if it's all nonsense what i mean i
this is my take on all this like be just
be a girl anything where you need
medical science to consistently yeah
right anything where you need medical
science to consistently inject chemicals
into your body they're going to alter
your hormones irreversibly at a very
young age like why
why is that natural why are you saying
this is the this is what
what this person biologically or
psychologically needs are you sure it
seems like something that human beings
have constructed well it's particularly
damn weird if you insist that gender is
a social construct
yes it's like if it's a social construct
then what the hell are the hormones for
exactly so that was my point yeah he
didn't have an answer to that no no
that's not that's a rough one man that's
that's yeah okay so we're going to go
back to boston
okay okay so you said that's really
where things started for you so you
moved there where you were 13. and so
what did you get involved in first of
all like what kind of kid were you in
school
uh barely paid attention i was
i if if add is real i certainly had it
um and i was very very interested in
what i was interested in i was very
uninterested in people telling me what
to do and i essentially couldn't wait to
get out of school but i would excel at
things that i had interest in and the
initially was art i was i wanted to be a
comic book illustrator until i really
got into martial arts and martial arts
became the focus of my life
around 14 15 years old that's when i
really
became massively obsessed and that was
really the first thing that i ever did
where i i really didn't feel like a
loser like i really felt like oh i
actually have some talent
i actually can be exceptional there's
like something it's like you know i grew
up
constantly moving didn't really have a
lot of friends i would be new in this
town i'd get picked on i wasn't a big
kid
and there was a lot of a lot of issues
with that psychologically and uh i
didn't like being afraid of other kids i
didn't like not knowing what to do
overran into kids they were going to
bully me and pick on me
so uh i learned yeah well that's an
annoying thing not to know what to do
about
yeah
and um
you know martial arts changed that 180
degrees and then i became someone who i
would be afraid of you know i became the
opposite of what i was
so what i was was someone who was
terrified of conflict didn't know what
to do and what i became was you know a
taekwondo champion i became a martial
arts champion and i knew how to fight so
i haven't done it so many times
so like what did you do you just walked
into a joint one day and decided that
that's what you were going to do like
how did it come about
it was very fortunate well i've done a
little bit of martial arts training at a
different place and then one day i was
in boston for a red sox game at fenway
park and as i was walking home to the
train station uh with a friend of mine
um
there was a lot of people that were
leaving the baseball game so the lines
from the train for the t uh which in
boston um public transportation was very
long
so uh we decided to go check out the j
hun kim taekwondo institute it's right
there and i've been really into martial
arts because of what i said you know
about the aforementioned
insecurities and
so i went up the stairs and as i was
walking up the stairs just
fortuitously
a guy named john lee was training and
john was a national taekwondo champion
who was uh in preparation for the world
cup which was this huge event that he
was taking the international event that
he was about to travel to go to and uh
he was in the peak of his training and
so i walked up to the top of the stairs
and i i heard this crazy sound of this
what it turned out to be this man
kicking this bag and slamming his heel
into this bag and having the chain snap
and
and rattle and the the thud of his heel
slamming into this leather bag
and i got up there and i watched this
guy work out
i couldn't believe a person could do
that i'd never seen anybody kick
something so hard in real life anybody
that had such an incredible martial arts
skill like this guy did john lee who
became a mentor of mine and and taught
me quite a bit
but uh that changed everything i was
there the next day i talked to them they
gave me a brochure and a pamphlet
and i was there the next day and i was
probably there every day of my life
um
give or take a few days here or there if
i was injured or something came up until
i was uh 22 years old
so how many hours a day were you
spending there
all day i had keys pretty quickly um
they gave me keys uh they wanted me well
right away my instructor recognized that
i was pretty obsessed and i was uh
physically pretty talented
so he uh
had me teaching classes uh instead of
paying
he was like like if it's difficult for
you to pay i'd like to have you teach
and there was some wisdom to that too
because one of the best ways for someone
to get good at martial arts is actually
to teach
you actually refines your technique you
you think about it more you're extending
it to people that don't necessarily
understand all the mechanics of it so i
started teaching i would teach private
lessons to beginners i would teach group
classes and then eventually i went on to
teach at boston university i taught at
boston university and when i was 19. i
was teaching accredited class there but
you actually it counted towards your gpa
and so uh i did that and that was i was
already us open champion by then and how
long did it take so you went in there
when you were 13 and you were a kid that
was had moved around a bunch and got
pushed i was 14 or 15 by the time i got
to that school okay uh and then i had my
black belt by the time i was 17 and i
was uh competing in the adult division
by then before i was ever 18 i was
competing as an adult
i mean he might even put me in when i
was 16 if i don't if i remember
correctly
and then i won the state championship
when i was 18 and i won it every year
um from then until i stopped
right so you had to pretty much i wanted
four years
there how long did it take before like
were we're used
were you still were you a thin like you
were you skinny kid when you started how
when did you start to bulk up and get
big when did you start tough enough so
that you know the problems with
aggression stop
you know with other people's aggression
stop being a being of trouble for you
well luckily with high school kids heard
about it
right away
you know it was one of those things
where you know you find out that there's
some
one one of the kids you go to school
with is flying all over the country
kicking people in the head
right they just avoided me yeah right i
became
it wasn't like
you know i mean i certainly never sought
out trouble but
people avoided me like you know junior
and senior year i'd already become this
weird kid
that was obsessed with martial arts you
know and i spent you know most of my
life from the time i was 15 until i was
training and competing i probably fought
over a hundred times i traveled all over
the country i fought in california i
fought in ohio i fought i fought all
over the place
a lot of
local tournaments in connecticut and
massachusetts and new hampshire is where
i won the u.s open and
i've you know just fought everywhere and
that was that was mostly my life yeah it
was most of my life until i got into
stand-up comedy
right so that was so he had a very
singular life like that's that's yeah
100 singular yeah uniquely singular but
i avoided most of the pitfalls of high
school partying and all that stuff i
didn't do that because i was scared of
getting hurt i was scared that if i
showed up for training hung over that i
would get beat up uh and that it would
somehow i was scared of anything that
would take even a tiny bit away from my
performance as a fighter because i was
was that actually fear of of of being
hurt because you made a mistake or fear
of losing the competition or
fear of fear of being hurt fear of
losing competition
fear of hurt being hurt in training
training alone was as scary as any
competition i just just complete
completely by luck wandered into one of
the best schools in the world for
taekwondo that it hit
they had produced multiple national
champions
and uh you know real
top of the food chain athletes in terms
of taekwondo it was just just dumb luck
that i walked into that school and you
know i could have walked into another
school that was a few blocks away that
was terrible
right i just got lucky i got really
really really lucky
so how useful
how useful are the technical martial
arts like taekwondo and like in an
actual street fight
not that useful i mean more useful than
knowing nothing
but um
not as useful as brazilian jiu jitsu or
uh now
a lot of people now are just learning
mixed martial arts right which is
essentially what you see in the ufc
where they're a jack of all trades
master of none and the argument there's
two arguments like there's there's an
argument that that is a good thing to
learn
and then there's other arguments that
being a specialist first is the best
thing and then learning the other things
later in life is the best way to go
about it like a specialist
particularly a striker or a grappler
like being an elite wrestler or an elite
jiu jitsu artist and then learning all
the other stuff later in life because
you have such a significant advantage if
you can bring the fight into your realm
of expertise
so if you are a striker every fight
starts standing up and if you're an
elite striker and you know how to avoid
takedowns and you know how to wrestle
enough to keep a guy off you you'll have
such a significant advantage striking
that you can dominate the competition
and we've seen that in the ufc we've
seen that with both grappling and with
uh with striking that it seems that if
you become a specialist in one
particular area and then learn those
other things you'll be better off but
you can't really just be a specialist
whether it's in muay thai or taekwondo
or jujitsu you really kind of have to
understand
if you're a grappler you really have
kind of have to understand striking
and if you're a striker you really kind
of have to understand grappling in order
to at least avoid it
so and so during this time too i mean
you got to be a pretty big guy so when
did that start happening were you
working out like mad while you were
training as well like yeah but i was
much thinner i was much thinner back
then i didn't do much weight lifting
because i was trying to compete in
certain weight classes like when i was
was one it was the i was cutting weight
when i was 17 and 18. i was trying to
make the 140 pound weight class but it
was really probably about 10 pounds plus
heavier than that and i would dehydrate
myself and it was really affecting my
performance and then when i was 18 i
moved up to the next weight class that
was 154 i believe it was and when i
moved up to that weight class i got way
better that was when i really excelled
that's when i became
like a real national class athlete was
when i moved up and um i would but i
still wasn't lifting weights much i was
just doing taekwondo training it was
just a lot of heavy bag work some
calisthenics but mostly it was martial
arts work then when i started getting
into jiu jitsu it was long after i
stopped competing that's when i started
really getting into weightlifting
because jiu-jitsu
involves
grappling and i think the the advantage
to being strong and grappling is pretty
significant very it's gigantic
and so that's when you know it was like
29 or so like that that's when i really
started heavily weightlifting and and so
that
was quite a bit later how long did your
initial martial arts career last
i thought from the time i was 15 and i
think i had my last fight it was either
i was 21 or 22 i don't really remember
those but the last three fights were
kickboxing fights and i had those while
i was doing stand-up comedy
so i was i was i was spreading myself
too thin i was working
a bunch of different jobs i was working
delivering newspapers i was working as a
private investigators assistant i did
some construction i did a bunch of
different odd jobs to make a living
and i had decided somewhere alone
newspaper yeah delivery boy construction
agent jiu jitsu fighter stand up
comedian you know that's kind of your
typical 19 year old situation
yeah well jiu-jitsu came later jiu-jitsu
didn't come until i was i think i was 28
or 29 when i first started training jiu
jitsu
um those
that was mostly just taekwondo and
kickboxing i really got into kickboxing
and i was entered i had three kickboxing
fights and i was entertaining the idea
of fighting professionally but i was
also starting to get really worried
about brain damage
uh i started to see some sometimes from
kickboxing specifically
yeah specifically because it was i was
getting hit a lot more oh yeah the the
kickboxing sparring that i did i did
that over the course of about two years
where i really got heavily into
kickboxing i did a lot of boxing
sparring and a lot of what you call gym
wars where guys would just we would beat
the [ __ ] out of each other and you'd get
hurt and you'd come home with headaches
and
you basically were fighting in the gym i
mean it's not a wise way to do it the
smart gyms now and the best martial
artists they very rarely spar hard they
most of the time they spark technically
so they're they're hitting each other
but they hit each other like this they
don't they don't blast each other full
blast they sort of touch each other
they're working on timing and
occasionally you go hard just to make
sure that you you can survive with these
techniques in a firefight that you know
how to deal with it once you get hit
but um we didn't is that the is the
lower combat intensity still
still useful for training for the real
thing
yes it's it's but you have to have some
high intensity and some people they have
that high intensity they actually have
drills that they use to to sort of
um to simulate actual uh exchanges that
you would have there's a lot of science
to it now that didn't exist back then
the the gyms that i came up in were real
hard nose
really
you know tough gyms and
if you if you weren't tough you did not
survive and they weren't interested in
anybody that couldn't take a shot or
anybody that wasn't willing to go to war
so you would put on a mouthpiece you put
on a cup you put your shin pads on and
you beat the [ __ ] out of each other and
that was a big part of uh learning how
to fight it was these sparring sessions
were brutal they were nerve-wracking
you'd be scared you'd be scared going
into them they'd be uh you know i'd be
anxious the night before if i knew how
to spar a particular guy the next day
because i knew it was dangerous you
basically were having fights all the
time so i'd have fights several days a
week you would fight you know it wasn't
really sparring you would hit i'd hit
guys like you're covering a lot too man
all the time i think from that so okay
yeah you're just a big hole in this
story too so like you're doing great at
taekwondo you've got your national level
athlete
and you switch to kickboxing you're
worried about getting hurt and that
seems reasonable because like how about
not being brain damaged by the time
you're 30 but then
you know
i guess kind of what i wondered was like
how many shots in the head did you have
to take before you thought being a
stand-up comedian was a good idea
well
um one of my dear friends to this day is
a guy named steve graham
and uh
steve was when i met him i was 15 and he
was
probably
and he was going through his residency
as an ophthalmologist
and
he had been a flight surgeon in the u.s
air force and just uh he would he had
been on the u.s ski team who's a
national skiing champion just a wild man
just a guy who took chances and lived
life to the fullest and was
just one of the most hard-working people
i ever met in my life
and
i would make him laugh
and i would make some of the people
laugh and training because we were
always nervous every when we would go to
tournaments we were nervous because you
know i'd seen many of my friends get
knocked unconscious at these tournaments
get kicked in the head
taken to hospitals and you know i'd seen
it in the gym too a lot of guys getting
beat up and knocked down in the gym
it was constant and you know and you
know it happened to me a couple times
i'd been hurt and
so we had this gallows humor where um we
would go to these events
we'd travel to these tournaments and
everybody would be the tension be so
thick everybody would just taking deep
breaths and trying to relax and just
stay loose before you fight and i would
be
the i would be the class clown in that
environment and have you ever seen that
when you were in high school or junior
high like no i didn't have that
so but i feel circumstances
yes i did have a sense of humor but it
would manifest itself in cartoons i
would draw like cartoons of the teacher
you know i would like draw cartoons of
like certain kids that would kiss the
teacher's ass i would draw them like
kissing the teacher's ass and saying
ridiculous things and if the teacher was
late to a class and you know and i knew
i had enough time i would put something
on the chalkboard and then pull down the
screen so that when they would go to use
the chalkboard the chalkboard they would
pull the screen back up and see this
ridiculous cartoon that i had drawn the
whole class would laugh and then the
teacher would ask who did this and
luckily nobody ratted me out but uh so i
that i
enjoyed making people laugh
but uh that was
i wasn't it wasn't most it mostly wasn't
things i said was mostly cartoons right
but that's very different yeah
yeah but with comedy with with the
the fighting when we were getting ready
to compete i was just trying to add some
levity i was just trying to lighten up
the mood because everybody was
and it was also
it was a charged environment so anything
that i said that was actually funny
would get a giant reaction and that
became addictive and i was pretty good
at doing impressions so i do impressions
of our friends do impressions of our
instructor all these in
ridiculous situations and my friend
steve graham and my other friend ed
shorter who's another one encouraged me
who i lost touch with unfortunately
he
he said you should be a comedian
and
my take on it was
you think i'm funny because you're my
friend
but other people are gonna think i'm an
[ __ ] like the things that i think are
funny are [ __ ] up right like i have a
[ __ ] up sense of humor i mean here i
am devoting most of my time to trying to
get really good at knocking people
unconscious i mean that's what i was
those that's what i was trying to do i
was trying to separate people from their
consciousness that was i was doing my
best every day to get good at that so my
it's like a really perverse psychedelic
drug
yeah i was
the worst yeah but it was i was trying
to hurt people that's what i was trying
to get good at i was trying to get good
at hurting human bodies
and i just didn't think i thought that i
was such an uh such a weirdo and such an
outlier in terms of like how society
viewed uh
combat physical hand-to-hand combat and
interactions with each other that no one
would think that the things that i was
making fun of were funny and this guy
convinced me to go to an open mic night
he's like you should go to an open mic
night
just go there's a lot of comedy clubs in
boston go and watch and i went and
watched and i realized wow one of the
things about going to open mic night is
most open mic comedians are so terrible
that it encourages you to try it because
you're like well i can't be that bad
like it i i might have something that's
better than some of these people and
then you know you'd see a real
professional go up and you'd it would be
so discouraging because you'd say like
god my god i'll never be that funny
that guy's impossibly funny uh but i
knew
from martial arts that if i worked
really hard at something i could get
good at it
and i had this thought that maybe i
could do that with comedy because i
didn't want to fight anymore i was
already i was already on my way kind of
out the door i was really worried about
the brain dead i was on my way out the
door
from the time i was like 19. from the
time i was 19 i was starting to worry
about brain damage and then so you're
how like you're 53
i'm 51. 51 51 and so much how much
damage did you actually sustain you know
like lots of people i don't know
i don't know
i mean
okay how about physically muscularly and
that sort of thing oh no i'm fine i had
a bunch of surgeries i've had my nose
repaired my nose was destroyed i i had
no nose like the inside of my nose was
just didn't work until i was 40. and
then i had a deviated septum operation
they had to cut out
giant calcified chunks of scar tissue
and all sorts of i literally my nose was
useless until i was 40 years old um so
that must be kind of a relief to have
your nose oh my god i tell everybody get
it done
if you have a deviated septum and you
can't breathe out of your nose my god
this
i couldn't do that until i was 40. yeah
it was just all bro i broke my nose who
knows how many times at least a dozen
and it would just was always
bloody i was always getting punched or
kicked in the nose yeah it doesn't seem
designed as a sense organ to be at the
in the middle of your face where you get
punched
well it has this little tiny piece of
cartilage too it should be on the top of
your head
you know
a lot safer up there
yeah like a whale
it also makes your eyes swell shut it
makes your eyes water makes it difficult
to see when you get hit in the nose the
hitting the nose is really annoying um
but other than that i had both my knees
reconstructed acl tears in both knees
how to get them them reconstructed and
you know a bunch of other stuff oh yeah
so you took your bunch of other broken
things
yeah broke yourself up pretty good feet
yeah broken knuckles and i broke a lot
of stuff
but uh but everything works great now i
mean after surgery and i mean for a
person who's been through what i do what
i've done with my body my body works
remarkably well yeah it's amazing
actually you know that's a lot yeah do
you think you'd be arthritic at least in
some of your joints and that sort of
thing
you know i'm pretty good i mean i also
are very proactive i do a lot of yoga
i've had a bunch of stem cell therapies
to deal with uh some significant tears
and injuries that i've had but all that
you know knock on wood everything works
pretty good but the brain damage thing
is i don't know i really don't know i
really
sit back and think about some of those
wars that i was in yeah gym wars in
particular and some fights and my last
fight i got tko'd i got stopped i got
hit with a left hook and dropped and my
legs went out from under me and then i
got up and i got hit again fell down
again they stopped the fight
and
that was when i decided
i'm gonna stop i was like i'm not giving
this the same amount of dedication i
gave when i was at my best i was
spreading myself way too thin with
comedy and i i just didn't i didn't have
this same hunger for it that i had when
i was young or younger and i was also
very aware of the consequences at that
point in my life i was like this i know
where this is going i i saw guys at the
gym that were punch drunk
you know that were slurring their words
and they would forget things and and i
had seen some people progress towards
that and it was very very disturbing to
me you know i'd be lying in bed at night
after a hard sparring session my head
would be pounding and i would think what
am i doing to my [ __ ] brain like what
am i doing to myself
and um
i got real lucky that i found stand-up
comedy i mean if the ufc was around back
then i most certainly would have started
fighting and you know and
to not be training intelligently because
i wasn't training intelligently i was
training like a meathead and that was
just all we knew back then
i probably would have sustained some
pretty significant damage before i ever
even got into the octagon i probably
would have already had massive brain
damage before i ever had a fight
right right so you so well that's good
so you you stepped out at an intelligent
time and so then you started your comedy
career and you started at
open mics and so like yeah tell me about
how that developed
well open mic nights are very
interesting you sign up on a list and
you may or may not get on uh they pick
people out of a hat like say if there's
50 people sign up 30 people get on and
uh you know you each do five minutes and
you know the the host is generally a
professional comedian that brings people
up and you know you have this weird
culture of people that are
struggling to try to figure out how to
make a living in this sort of uh
undefined art form there's no classes
you can take in it that are really worth
anything there's no books that you could
buy that are going to teach you anything
it's something that you kind of have to
the only thing that i liken to is rap
music because rap music seems to be very
similar in the fact that you have to
learn from other practitioners you don't
really learn from books you don't
there's no like i mean maybe there is
now
i don't know of any like real legitimate
university courses on stand-up comedy
i i don't think they could teach it to
you anyway because everyone does it
differently but i think that's the case
with rap music as well i think you kind
of have to learn from the people that
are already doing it and one good thing
about stand-up comedy particularly today
today it's much more open and inviting
and
comedians have a lot more camaraderie
than they did in the beginning because
they're not fighting over scraps anymore
now there's so many venues so many
different places to work and then
there's youtube
and the internet and um comedians
there's much more of a supportive
community of people trying to help
people and i i try to really concentrate
on that i spend a lot of time trying to
help young comics
i put a lot of young comics on my shows
i have them host um you know i've got a
show tonight and uh a young comic has
only been doing it for a few years her
name's uh ali makovsky she's the host of
it she's really funny and i try to
encourage them i try to help them i try
to give them advice and try to give them
pointers i try to when they have great
sets i try to you know really thank them
and say that was excellent and you got
this just keep keep doing what you're
doing and you can really make a career
doing this because it's such a insecure
business it's just so it's such a weird
undefined path that you have to take
it's
and i love the art form i love it as a
consumer i love it as a person who's an
audience member i really still to this
day enjoy watching stand up
but back then
it wasn't that supportive it was you
know we would just support each other
but the the professionals weren't that
supportive not like they are today a few
people there's a guy named lenny clark
that i'm still good friends with to this
day and i i opened up for he was a
boston legend and i was super fortunate
to open up for him when i had been uh
doing comedy for about a year and he
gave me some great advice and that meant
the world to me and he was actually on
my podcast just last month i love that
guy and you know he helped me out when i
was really really i was 21 i was really
really young on my comedy career and so
you started putting the same amount of
dedication into that that you had been
putting into the martial arts
exactly yeah i just became obsessed with
it and i just traveled all over the
place doing doing open mic nights i mean
me and my good friend greg fitzsimmons
we started out together we're good
friends to this day we started out
within a week of each other and um we we
used to travel all the way to rhode
island we would drive you know it was an
hour plus drive to go down there just to
do five minutes and then we had an open
mic night for free and they would drive
all the way home and just dream about
one day being a professional that was
the dream the dream was to pay your
bills by doing comedy imagine if that
that you could do comedy for a living
like that was the dream would i would
never imagine that i'm doing what i'm
doing now or i'm doing these sold out
arenas like that
but that wasn't even
a hope and not it wasn't even like maybe
if it goes well i could do this maybe i
could do that that was never on the menu
and you know it's gotten to this really
crazy astronomical
place now that it's very hard for me to
even imagine that that came out of
those
strange days in boston just traveling
around all these different weird comedy
clubs and writing constantly not knowing
how to write not knowing how to
formulate a joke having like
many more misses than hits you know a
lot of bombing i bombed all the time
you know
you've got to have that ability to
to bomb and come back from it i mean
because yeah
you're going to have a lot more
misses than hits that's for sure that's
a lot more yeah especially in the early
days what do you think accounts for that
obsessiveness that you described and
that's a negative way of putting it i
mean obviously you said that you know
when you're in school if you weren't
interested you weren't listening at all
but if you were interested in something
you were like laser focused and that
really came up in the martial arts but
obviously manifested itself in the
stand-up comedy too so what is it about
you that
that enables you what do you think it is
about you that enables you to
zero in on something like that to the
exclusion of everything else
i don't know i mean i think some of it
has to be attributed to the unhappiness
of my childhood um that when i would
find something that i did get some joy
out of i would just
concentrate
all in on that
um i think some of it also was like i
wasn't really raised with a lot of
discipline and i wasn't really raised
with a
pat my parents were both my stepdad and
my mom were both working all the time so
they they didn't they weren't really
around to sort of tell me what to do or
how to live and they weren't really
around to let me know that everything
was gonna be okay they were always
working so they would come home from
work at like six o'clock or something
like that and
you know i'd been
on my own all day me and my sister had
been on our own all day you know we'd
come home we had a key we got into the
house and
it was uh when i there was a lot of
real bad feelings you know like
and when i found something that made me
feel good i just did that exclusively
that's all i did and i i still have that
problem to this day
when i get obsessed with something if i
find something that means something to
me
i uh
i think of it
all day long if i get obsessed with
something it becomes
it becomes uh like a mantra that's in
the back of my head and i i
i have to
shut it off
like i have to do my best to shut it off
otherwise i can't listen to people i
don't like like when people are talking
to me i don't want to talk to them i
want to go do that thing that i want to
do right right you know it becomes like
a compulsion
and it could be socially negative you
know it could be uh detrimental to
relationships and friendships yeah um
yeah but it seems like that sort of
thing is also
absolutely necessary if you're going to
develop high-level skill at something
difficult and unlikely because yeah
unless you're obsessive about it
practice it like all the time
the the people you're competing with are
gonna they're gonna take you out
so wow funny thing i would always be
terrified that i would run into someone
like me
well i cannot that's what i was
terrified
but that's that was the fear that i
would run into someone who is a hundred
percent all in and when i was
fighting and when i lost my last
kickboxing fight i wasn't all in and i
knew i wasn't awesome
and i knew i knew i wasn't the same
person i was when i was like 18 19 i was
a psychopath i mean i was
100 committed to doing nothing but that
and then um as i was examining my future
prospects in my life and i started to
become
more aware of the problems of what i was
doing i became less and less i had one
fight that i had in california and
anaheim in the u.s nationals in 1980
it must have been
my
it seems like it had to have been 86
86 or 87
somewhere around there
somewhere around 87. i i knocked this
guy out with a head kick and i did in
front of his parents
and it was
it was
everybody was people were crying and he
was unconscious for a long time he was
unconscious for a solid half hour
and they dragged him they dragged him
off of the uh the mat they put him in a
stretcher they took him to the hospital
i never saw him regain consciousness
and uh i remember thinking that could
have easily been me like i didn't have
any illusions of me being some
impervious invulnerable person
and i was really thinking about how
i hit him so hard my heel was hurting
the next day i was walking with a limp
from his head
because i wheel kicked him in the head
it's a particularly brutal move where
you spin and your your whole leg comes
around you're hitting someone in the
head with your heel and he felt like he
had gotten shot just fell face first
out cold snoring
it wasn't the first time that i'd done
that to someone but it was
one of the most brutal because he kind
of ran into it too he was trying to kick
me as i was kicking him so it was the
force of his body coming towards me and
me hitting him and i was thinking that
guy's probably never going to be the
same again
like he's never going to get over it
psychologically or if he does it's going
to be very hard for him
but he might
he might be damaged for the rest of his
life that's a real possibility and then
i started thinking am i willing to have
that happen to me at 19. i was 19 years
old i was like is this is this what you
want to do do you want to get hit in the
head like that and never be the same
again at 19 because it easily can happen
you know yeah that's what we were at 60
years to live like that
yeah we were at a this was a national
championship tournament so he was a
state championship i think from illinois
and i was a state champion from
massachusetts
and um you know it wasn't like he was he
was a black belt and it wasn't like he
was a unskilled guy
so the fact that i was able to do that
to him and i was able to do that to a
bunch of other guys i knew that someone
out there could do that to me right i
knew that i knew that i wasn't the best
in the world and i knew that even though
i was a top i was you know i was a real
national level competitor i wasn't world
class i wasn't the best
especially at 19.
um and so that doubt
that doubt stuck with me
um for the next couple of years and it
was it was probably the first seed
of my new future was me hurting that guy
and thinking about what that was going
to be like if that happened to me
yeah well that's a hell of a right turn
you took there to go into comedy so okay
so how now you became successful as a
comedian
so you started playing in little clubs
like stand-up comedians did and like
yeah how did you get your breaks and
how'd your career develop
well um
it took a few years for me to get
competent you know it took like two or
three years for me to get competent and
then
three years in i got extremely fortunate
again where i met my manager my manager
who's my manager to this day he
basically picked me up when i was an
open mic comedian i mean i was i was
getting a few paid gigs here and there
but i was really an amateur
um
and he found me
he was looking for new talent he came up
from new york he is he was a like you
know really well respected and well
recognized manager still is
of course his name is jeff sussman and
we've been together for uh [ __ ] now it
must be 28 years
yeah we've been together since really
since i was an amateur and he uh
that's a successful collaboration to to
span that amount of time not many
changes
yeah um yeah we've been together forever
we've been together forever we don't
even have a contract anymore
we haven't had a contract i think for
like 10 years so during all this time
this is just like a bit of a side
side question here but you never have
any time at all to pursue relationships
with women
no yeah well you do comedy you know
you're in clubs at night yeah you have
most of your day to do whatever you want
you know to just when i was just a
stand-up comedian i had a lot of free
time
you know i mean you're writing jokes but
you can only do that a couple hours a
day or you get bored and then it's not
effective and then you're just kind of
living your life and hanging out and
sometimes the best way to develop your
comedy is to have good social
interactions it's actually kind of
important when you're an aspiring
comedian to be in a lot of social
situations
because you're around people you hear
people say things
and then you think what they say is
silly or what they say is you know you
disagree or you agree you you see
perspectives and points of view
and you kind of
you develop
you know
an understanding of how human beings
behave it's kind of very important so
yeah i i was around a lot of different
girls and a lot of guys and just being
out and and you're always at comedy
clubs and nightclubs but i didn't i
didn't go out other than that you know
if i wasn't at a comedy club at night i
probably wasn't out
you know it was always the same thing
with like
my obsession with fighting and fighting
came way easier for me than standup did
stand up was way harder for me it was
way harder it was way harder
what was harder about it well you said
it took you two or three years to get
competent so that was a lot of fallen
flat on your face i presume yeah
and even then even like three years in i
still could bomb at any moment
i mean i could have a bad set i didn't
know how to do it but also i was
socially awkward i think it took me a
while to uh
to not be
not be so socially awkward you know that
was that was an issue and you know
it was a lot of it was
from my upbringing but a lot of it was
also i kind of cultivated that when i
was fighting yeah i didn't want people
to like me i didn't care
like i didn't need them to like me all i
needed them to do i mean i kind of
wanted them to be scared of me you know
i so when i was fighting i wasn't trying
to make friends out there at all
i was uh i was just trying to [ __ ]
people up i mean so when you were
fighting when we were fighting did you
have any relationships with women or was
it or were you pretty not good ones
no i didn't i wouldn't allow them to do
i wouldn't allow them to have much of my
time
you know i i didn't
i didn't uh
i didn't i think to have a successful
relationship you have to spend a lot of
time together you have to communicate
you have to you the the person has to
almost be first place in your life yeah
and that was never that was never
happening and so that was that would
come up very often like i was a girl
that i was dating in high school uh and
you know i used to teach at the school
so i had keys to the school so um one
time i took her up there because i
needed to get a workout in and she
wanted to have sex
at the gym and i was like there's no way
i wouldn't do it i was like this place
is sacred like there's no chance like
she was trying to fool around and i was
and i was adamant i was like this is
never happening like this
might as well be a church to me
i was like it's not happening and you
know i was so horny when i was 17 years
old to
17 or 18 to say no to sex was crazy
right right
not happening i think we're gonna we're
gonna clip that and put it in a little
clip that says joe rogan tells a story
that no sane man would believe
well you know i was that was the first
refuge that i had from my life of
despair so for me i wasn't going to
screw that up right
right right and i felt like
disrespecting the the the academy like
that yeah
yes that's something when you're a
teenager you know like to actually be
treated that way it's a good thing not
to mess with if you're fortunate enough
to have it
well i wouldn't even walk onto the
training floor by myself with no one
around without bowing
uh-huh
i mean there was no one there but i
would never
leave the the common area and step on
the training floor without bowing first
right never never
never okay so when you're in comedy now
you said you said you were all in as a
fighter and you figured you went all in
as a comedian too and did you do that
right from the beginning
yeah yeah pretty much yeah right away as
soon as i realized that i could actually
do this and as soon as i realized i
decided i mean my first set that i ever
did i had a bunch of my friends come
down and watch me i wasn't good the
first time i ever got on stage but i got
a couple of little chuckles and laughs
and then i realized this might be
possible i might be able to do this and
then i became obsessed with figuring out
how to do it because it was i i saw it
as a path like okay this is a thing like
this is a thing you could do that you
actually love like i was a huge fan of
the art form i loved watching it um ever
since my parents took me to the movies
when i was like 14 or 15 we saw live on
the sunset strip it was a richard pryor
movie uh in in the theater where he did
stand up and i'd never seen that before
and i remember thinking how crazy is it
that this guy can just talk
and it's so funny i was falling out of
my chair laughing and i was looking
around i remember looking around while
the movie was playing and all these
people in their chairs just rocking back
and forth and laughing so hard
that's really something that's amazing
i saw especially when you're a young
teenager like
i know you should oh really talk about
bill cosby but i saw him live and like i
saw him live too when i was a security
guard oh yeah i saw him yeah i was a
security guard at great woods uh i saw
kennis in there when i was a security
guard and saw rodney dangerfield there
yeah saw quite a few people there yeah
well it was something to see him sit on
his stool with his cigar and
get the whole audience like literally
hysterical i mean the guy in front of
him was
walking back and forth so hard he could
hardly breathe his wife kept elbowing
him to get him to kind of you know turn
back into something vaguely resembling a
human being
but it was it's really amazing to see
someone with that much command of the
audience and and so consistently
unbelievably funny
he's the most tragic story in all of
show business
next to michael jackson and oj simpson i
mean those are the three most tragic
stories in show business in in my mind
yeah and and you know he's a monster and
it's crazy yeah no one's brilliant
comedian what the hell you know the
thing that's so strange about cosby you
think well like
was this really necessary like
man the guy was famous in 15 different
directions and really well respected you
wouldn't have think he would have had to
rape his women you know it's just well
yeah i mean he if he just he could have
just had prostitutes i mean if he really
just needed sex i don't think that's
what it was i think there was a sick
perversion
and i think he liked to do that to
people he liked to trick them i mean i'm
just guessing right oh it has to be
something like that because it's so
it's so counterproductive and so
psychotic it's psychotic i mean i don't
understand it you know i've tried to
i've tried to sort of imagine what it
must have been like to be around in the
50s and the 60s i think people did that
to each other way more often than we'd
like to admit and i think that it was
more casual than we would think of today
where people would slip someone a mickey
or you know i mean he even had a bit
that he did back in way back in the day
about giving someone spanish fly that
you'd give someone something that would
make them horny right i think he i think
he was probably a guy that had an
incredibly inflated opinion of himself
didn't want anybody to ever reject him
experienced that a few times again this
is pure speculation and just decided
that he was better than people that he
could just drug them it's so strange
though because his comedy was basically
so like it was generally family oriented
it was yeah you know and he put himself
forward as a role model and he was
credible like he was credible as an
actor as a role model and he seemed
credible as a spokesperson
kind of kind of makes me think you know
there's this
idea that the psychoanalysts there's a
guy named eric neumann who is a student
of carl jung's and one of the things
that neumann said he wrote a book called
depth psychology and the new ethic right
after world war ii and it's a it's a
great book a little thin book but it's a
great book
one of the things he says in that book
is
don't be better than you are
and what he meant was he didn't mean
don't improve like he's never been
foolish he meant
beware of
adopting a persona that makes you
a far better person than you actually
are because all of that
part
of you that you're not admitting to
that's going to go off and have its own
life because you're not integrating it
you know you're suppressing it in some
way and you know what it and and so it's
a living thing you know that well like
the aggression you had when you were a
fighter that's a big deep part of you
you know you can't just push something
like that aside and pretend that it's
not there and think that it's not going
to go off and have some fun when you're
not paying attention
yeah to me like something like that must
have got him is that he was
he was split between this really good
guy that he was trying to be which was
like too good
and
and and this this like more monstrous
side of his personality that he
obviously never integrated or perhaps
never even admitted to it's really a
hell of a story man it's like and it
really is a catastrophe i think it was
an absolute bloody catastrophe for his
victims obviously and but just as a
general cultural phenomenon is so awful
yeah i couldn't agree more and it you
you know you they say you should
separate the man from the art
but in his case it's almost impossible
to do because his art was his perception
of life so like when you're watching him
it's not like a painter or even someone
who makes a movie it's like when you're
watching him you're watching him now and
all you can think of as he's talking
about these different things and about i
told my children well he's like he's
doing this lovable dad yes and you know
all you can think of that guy rapes
people he drugs them and rapes them yeah
yeah yeah
i can't enjoy it anymore and he's
unquestionably as far as like his skill
he was one of the greatest of all time
yeah yeah all right so you got
you got a manager and you got a good one
and what happened yeah
uh i moved to new york and then uh once
i moved to new york i started
doing a ton of stand-up comedy uh i was
traveling all over the place and i got
better and better and i kept working on
it working on it and just doing a lot of
gigs and just going all over the place
and and then um a few years later how
old were you about how old were you by
the time you were like paying your bills
because that was your first marker for
success probably like 26
25 26 was when it all started coming
together oh yeah so that's not too bad
that's not yeah i mean i wasn't
taking a lot of money
i was making enough money to eat and pay
my rent um and then um
somewhere around then i did a thing
called the mtv half hour comedy hour
that was a uh
it was a television show they had on mtv
and each comedian i mean i don't know
how much time i did on the show i think
you'd do like seven to ten minutes or
something like that it wasn't a lot of
time
and i had a set and i i did it on
television it went really well and then
uh next thing you know i got all these
offers
to do television shows i got development
deal offers and then
before you know it i'm living in
california it was like that i mean
within a year i was living in california
and i was on a sitcom
and uh
and then that sitcom got canceled and uh
i thought i was gonna move back to new
york it was called uh hardball
it was a baseball show on fox it was a
sitcom about a baseball team
um
that show got cancelled and then uh i
got a development deal with nbc i was
gonna move back to new york but i'd
signed a lease uh for my apartment i
hated la i hated actors i didn't like it
i didn't it was so it was so
disingenuous the worlds that i had come
from were the worlds of stand-up comedy
which is about as real as you can get
either you're funny or you're not and
then the world of fighting which is even
more real than that um and then all of a
sudden i was around
all these people
that were just full of [ __ ] and weird
and it was they were put on these
personas and they wanted the casting
agents to like them and the producers to
like them and everything was fake and
everybody knew it was fake but they all
accepted it and they talked fake and
they and it was it was very very strange
very hard for me to deal with i really
didn't like actors i didn't like being
and the only place that i sought refuge
it's a funny thing that there'd be an
automatic assumption that because you
were a good stand-up comedian that
somehow you'd be an actor
yeah to be the same thing
no they're not but
the thing is that a lot of comedians had
gone on to be super successful in the
world of sitcoms like roseanne barr
jerry seinfeld tim allen those type of
people they had these huge careers brett
butler so because of that all that was
happening at the same time this was like
in 94ish when i got on tv for the first
time
um and they that was what they were
pushing and then agents and managers who
pushed that too because obviously you
could make a tremendous amount of money
so uh that show got cancelled but i have
a lease for this apartment so i was kind
of stuck in la so i was like all right
let me just stay out here and uh see
what happens for a year that was my
thought and then um i got a development
deal with nbc they wanted to do a sitcom
with me and then i wound up auditioning
for a show that they had already had
called news radio and that was with dave
foley and phil hartman and maura tierney
and candy alexander and steven root and
andy dick and
vicky lewis and we did that show for
five years
and then um you know by that time
uh i had done a lot of stand up at the
comedy store when that show was canceled
fear factor came along and i was touring
as a comedian and now that's still there
okay so now you go from sitcoms to fear
factor
so how the hell did that happen
and why well it happened
nbc came up to me with the idea because
i was on nbc previously and they they
liked me and then part of the thing was
that i didn't want to work with actors
anymore
i was i was happy that fear factor was
no actors and i was like oh good this is
easier to do um it's just me talking to
people and
since i had a background in coaching
because i had coached a lot of people at
tournaments uh in competition and i
taught a lot at boston university i
taught at my own school um i you know
with taekwondo i was used to teaching
people and i was used to encouraging
people and and getting people motivated
and i knew how to i knew how to get
fired up for competition i understood
you were actually you're actually one of
the rare people in the world who was
actually trained
to
be the right host for fear factor
yeah in a lot of ways
luckily fortuitously because i i like i
would when someone was nervous they're
about to do something i i could grab
them and go look at me you could do this
this is going to define you
if you back off right now and you get
scared and you give in to your fears and
your anxieties this is going to define
you or if you just press forward and
realize you can do this and succeed it
will define you in a positive way and
you'll build momentum in that direction
you can do this and i would i was really
good at giving people pep talks i was
really good at firing people up and it
was part of the gig that it was like it
was uh completely unexpected because i
thought the gig was just gonna be these
people do these crazy things and you
know i make fun of it which is part of
my job and i you know we all cheer and
and it would all play itself out because
it was a reality show it was sort of a
game show slash reality show was like a
hybrid
but somewhere along the line especially
when they became really nervous
uh it it was very intense
and there was moments where i really
i wanted these people to win you know i
wanted these people to do their best i
want these people to succeed
you know and to be able to encourage
someone
you know from yeah that's the basis of
psychotherapy
so
you know it's really something to get
people to
face their fears i mean you were doing
it in a very
s
idiosyncratic way
very a very
uh what unique way
but yeah imagine it was psychologically
compelling very often
got any particular got any particular
stories from that time you got a good
story from fear factor
well there was one time
where there was this couple uh not
couple a family it was a father and a
son competing against the mother and the
daughter
and the father and the son were kind of
jerks
which was part of the competition there
was a lot of trash talking
but they were really cocky and they
thought that they were gonna win you
know and it was you know they had
this
the parent and child teams had gotten
down to two and it was the man and his
son versus the woman and her daughter
and
everybody thought
these jerks were going to win we were
kind of bummed out about it
but
the the women the woman and her child
you know they just rose to the occasion
and
i mean i remember
talking to them and firing them up but i
still i didn't know if they could do it
what was the challenge
it was some crazy thing that they had to
climb and do this thing and
the the
i i don't really remember all of it like
they had to gather flags it was all for
time but the sun the kind of jerky sun
the jerky dad they kept screwing up
and they they [ __ ] up because you know
they'd they'd kind of taken it
for granted that they were going to win
and when the pressure hit them and they
knew it was all on the line a lot of
times jerks
are just insecure
and when they're under pressure when
they're really faced with real pressure
like this is the real moment who are you
really [ __ ] all that talk who are you
really they fall apart
and
the mother and the daughter won and
you're talking about a hardened crew of
people that had watched people eat
animal dicks and jump out of helicopters
for season after season episode after
episode you know we did
a hundred and something shows a hundred
and i don't even remember how many shows
like probably 140 episodes of that show
everybody cried
the camera people like i'll cry now if
i'm thinking about it
when the mother and the daughter was too
affecting
i mean there's a justice league to it
right
does it come up
it was a comeuppance it was an underdog
it was
just seeing
their spirit
you know when when they were figuring
out a way to win
watching them win or to this day
i'll tell you one of the things that
makes me really happy about this
interview so far is that like i have a
tendency to tear up in interviews um as
you may have noticed but this time it
was you so i'm i'm quite pleased about
that it's a very touch-up story though
man
you do eh
yeah yeah but particularly like that i
don't know if you're up for sad things
i tear up for happy things
you know
that's an interesting thing to to think
about too because it's not exactly happy
right it's
cuz you know when these people come up
to me and they tell me their stories
that often makes me tear up because it's
like it's like this blast of dead bloody
seriousness with a happy ending you know
so yeah it's a comedy
because it's a happy ending but it's
rough and effecting and it it it that
makes me tear up and i think my
proclivity i've always kind of had that
ever since i was a kid but it seems to
have come back
well you too eh
yeah yeah always always but it's always
been happy things it's never been sad
things it's very hard to get me to cry
with sad things exactly as i sort of
just yeah triumph success
yeah um
people pulling through like post-fight
interviews when i'm when i work for the
ufc when someone has like a particularly
incredible performance
i have to fight off tearing up
i feel
so happy for them
this isn't it strange that it's that
same response
to
sorrow
that's the same response to sorrow and
triumph
yeah
no like what the hell's up with that i
don't i don't understand that at all
i mean i guess it's also i have a sign
of empathy
yes it is definitely a sign of empathy
but it's what's also odd is that
with sad things i can i can
i can objectively analyze them
and i i could not get sad i could
understand that this is just life and it
is what it is and i mean i won't feel
good but i won't start weeping
i don't weep for
like sad things the way i weep for happy
things so you that's interesting so
so in some sense you've you've trained
yourself to detach yourself from that
kind of sorrow but not to detach
yourself from triumph
i can rationalize
and understand sorrow
i can internalize it i get it i know i
know what it is
and uh you know
i just get so happy for people sometimes
when things go well yeah one of my
guilty pleasures is i i really like uh
america's got talent and the bbc
equivalent what the hell is the bbc
equivalent is it the x factor
something like that yeah yeah and it
does the same thing to me i'd see
somebody schlub out there slob
themselves out there on the stage
looking pretty
pretty damn dreadful in about four
different dimensions and then like knock
it out of the park it really yeah
it's it's really something to
yeah there's something to see amazing
well because i think we per as a human
being you realize how hard it is to
overcome
competition or these difficult moments
so these these moments when you're
tested and you know there's fears and
insecurities that these people have to
battle as well as the actual physical
task in front of them there's so much
going on and there's so much
anticipation and nerves and anxiety
involved in that that to see someone
triumph i mean it's i am a student of
human will i love
stories of discipline and success i
don't like bad stuff i don't even like
going to movies where they're sad when
people tell me about sad movies i'm like
stop i'm not going that movie i don't
like it i don't want to see it i'm not
interested i know what sadness is i've
been sad i get it i'm not interested in
getting that in a form of entertainment
i like success i like i like seeing
people triumph i like i like seeing the
human spirit manifest itself in
spectacular ways yeah that's why i like
my lectures that's why it's so fun to do
them you know because i'm out there
trying to tell people that they have the
opportunity to do that and to point out
to them too that if they watch
themselves they notice they love that
because you know that's one of the
things you go to a
basketball game or a hockey game or
something like that and somebody makes a
spectacular play and it's a little
celebration of the human spirit
ability to do something impossible in
the moment and everybody's up on their
feet like in one second
go man go yeah that's yeah that's that's
uh
the more that the better as far as i'm
concerned there's so much
concentration on our mo on our you know
the destruction we wreak on the planet
and our original sin and our weakness
and
that you know the terrible things we do
to each other it's really nice to see
those situations where
people are celebrating the triumph of an
individual in a group like that and
really says something wonderful about
human beings deep in their core
for all of our problems it's really
something to be part of that
yeah i couldn't agree more and i think
we concentrate way too often and way too
much
on the negative aspects of people you
know i mean this is one of the things is
about the only place that doesn't happen
you know
it's kind of strange because you do
concentrate on the positive in sports
you celebrate the winners you know the
cameramen don't go over and interview
the losers
you know i mean yeah and all that but
and it's it i don't know why it is that
in sports it's okay to
just to celebrate the triumphant the
victorious but it is okay and no one
questions it it's it's are well that's
not true because now they have like
non-competitive games for kids and you
know that's part of the politically
correct curriculum but most of the time
most sane people will celebrate along
with a victorious athlete and that's
really something
all right so fear factor how many years
did that last
six years
were they good years
it was good financially
yeah well that's something i made a ton
of money and it alleviated financial
pressure but i enjoyed doing it
somewhat but it was not like the way i
enjoy the other things that i do it's
not like i enjoy stand-up comedy it's
not like i enjoy working for the ufc
it's not like i enjoy doing podcasts all
those things that i just talked about
those three things those things are
labors of love their passions are things
that i'm really
genuinely fascinated by and interested
in like this conversation i would have
this conversation with you if it was
just you and me and there was no cameras
i would love to have this conversation i
love having conversations with
interesting people um i love stand-up
comedy i love all those things i didn't
love being there for fear factor but it
was a great job and i knew it was a
great job and i knew i was really lucky
to have it so it was great in that
respect but when it was over i kind of
decided i was done with television
when it was over i was like okay i think
i'm done with this no more of this from
like from here on out i'm just gonna
concentrate on my own stuff
and so uh from then on out i just really
focused on stand-up comedy and that's
when my comedy
career really took off was post fear
factor i mean i had a comedy career
during fear factor but it really took
off post fear factor because i really
gave it all of my attention and so what
was what what happened after fear factor
that boosted you on the comedy on the
comedy circuit
um well i did a special for comedy
central and spike tv
called talking monkeys in space in 2009
that was like probably my best work up
until then
and then um you know from then i've been
on a pretty steady pace of doing
specials every two years or so ever
since then right right right and that's
been successful non-stop are you getting
better yeah and it's yeah i think i am i
think i'm getting better i think it's
one of those things as long as you keep
concentrating on it and as long as you
keep focusing on it you're getting
better i think my hour that i'm doing
now is as good as anything i've ever
done and it's not even done yet it's
only you know six months into this hour
but i think it's some of my best work
ever and i'm really excited to see where
it comes
well i mean probably there's no rush
because it's only six months since my
last one i probably will work on this
for another year
before i even think about recording it
oh yeah so if it's good don't should be
really good by then
yeah it's a it's like a samurai sword
you're folding the metal and hammering
the blade and folding the metal and
hammering the blade and you got to know
when it's ready and i'll start to get a
sense of where it's ready in about a
year in about one year then i'll start
going all right this seems pretty solid
maybe it's time to rock and roll and
then i'll contact netflix and i'll say
uh hey let's do it you know what so
set it up and whatever just whatever
city i decide
and i'll just i'll pick a city i'll pick
it i'll just run it over in my head i'll
pick a name for it
you know
well maybe i'll try to stay posted on
what you're doing and come down and see
it that'd be fun yeah i missed it last
time you're here in toronto but i'd like
to come and see one of your shows live i
think that'd be a blast
so yeah okay so
the next was the ufc
yeah that was tv
the ufc happened while i was on news
radio actually was on dunes radio i
started working for the ufc way back in
but it was the ufc was more of a
sideshow back then it was uh banned from
cable you could only get it on satellite
tv
right and
it was it was a freak show people didn't
know about it i mean i loved it because
as a lifelong martial artist to me it
was fascinating to watch all these
different styles compete against each
other
but um
it didn't pay much money
and even though it was enjoyable for me
it got in the way of other aspects of my
life and so i quit around 1998
and then um
somewhere along the line in around 2001
the ufc was purchased by this new
company and when they purchased this my
earphones are dying i'm gonna have to
take these off and
unplug this here
can you hear me still is that good
yeah
it's good okay um
once it started uh once uh the new
company took over
they were trying to get people to uh to
go to their events
and uh they asked me to go to the event
you know it's when i was doing fear
factor and so i went and watched it live
and uh when i was watching it live
um i was talking to dana white who is
the president of the ufc and just
talking about the sport and all these
different things i think about and
are you interested in this guy i was
asking about various obscure fighters
who were competing in japan
maybe he didn't know about you should
try to get these guys
and then somewhere along the line he
said hey you want to do commentary and i
i kind of i was like i don't want to
work man i'm just here i just want to
enjoy this so he and i became friends
and he talked me into doing it
and uh i first did it for free i did
like 12
events or so for free
just for fun i was like just get tickets
for my friends and i'll go and i'll do
commentary for you but i i didn't take
it that seriously i just i didn't ever
think it was going to be you know a
career right be this
you know
well-known commentator in mixed martial
arts i just thought i was doing it as a
favor for them and for fun for me
and uh you know lo and behold here we
are 18 years later
i'm still doing it
i presume they're paying down
what's up i presume they're paying you
now oh yeah they pay me a lot that's
good that's good that that's better
bargaining position i would say yeah
yeah it's they're very generous
okay so
so that that's kind of an understandable
transition in some sense because
you know
you got you you got your social skills
highly developed and you got your
ability to be witty on demand highly
developed and to pay attention to an
audience and you had the martial arts
background and so
ufc commentator that that makes sense
it's that all right so now
where does the podcast come in
how the hell does that happen next
yeah i guess it's next isn't it yeah the
podcast was 2009
i guess when it first started and the
podcast was basically
um it was just for fun it was like
something to do with my friends me and
my friend brian we just decided to set
up a laptop and people would ask
questions and we would just start
just talking about things and then it
became a weekly thing and then we
started uploading it to itunes and then
you know i started getting guests and
then
as the
i mean it took years before it was
profitable i mean i i just it was just
for fun forever like a lot of things
that i've done
it was originally just for fun well
that's pretty early podcast too though a
2009 so very early i mean podcasts were
i mean for lots of people they're still
not a thing although that's really
changed in the last
three or four years i mean yeah they're
definitely a mainstream
uh media phenomena now but 2009
i mean
that was that was fringe stuff
fundamentally
yes yeah it was very fringe there was uh
just a few advertising market at that
point i wouldn't have thought not much
no no there was no ads we didn't have
ads for years
um
and then um slowly ad started trickling
in the first ad was the fleshlight which
is a masturbation device
it was so it was a funny story about sam
harris sam harris who was a guest really
early on when the fleshlight was the
only sponsor
requested that we not have the
fleshlight as a sponsor on the episode
that he was on
and so i was like okay
so i i took the that week off i just
decided no uh no sponsor that week
and
that's funny
for very many reasons it's funny that
that was your first well you know
pornography leads the way right
yeah well you're doing the internet
yeah yeah it is kind of funny yeah and
you know
was even also funnier is that the guy
who was
um i guess he was the ceo of the
fleshlight or marketing something or
another flashlight
he went on
to form on it with me so on it which is
my fitness and supplement company he and
i are partners in this and it came out
of our
uh the thing with the fleshlight our
business agreement because it was really
profitable for the fleshlight and he
realized early on like wow like having a
podcast sponsor something can be
incredibly lucrative
if the podcast is well respected and
well received like this is sort of an
untapped advertising market hey let's
start a business and just use the
podcast as uh a method of launching this
business and let's see how it goes
right so the podcast that's
and that became very successful too but
the podcast sort of um
took on a life of its own it went from
being just me hanging out with comedians
talking to me interviewing people like
you
having conversations i should say more
than interviewing people like you and
you know scientists and archaeologists
and
doctors and you mean everyone world yeah
all right you started talking oh you
started talking to everyone
yeah everyone really everyone and it was
mostly mostly comedians to begin with
yes it was almost all comedians the
beginning and the everyone part is
interesting because that's something
that people
resist or resent more than anything now
like uh the thing about this that you
see now you see this this this
expression giving someone a platform why
would you give some of someone a
platform with those ideas it's like it
really comes down to this concept of
silencing opinions that you don't agree
with and my thought on it was has always
been i want to talk to all kinds of
different people
and even if i don't agree with them i
want to find out why they think the way
they yeah yeah yeah yeah well there's
also an element of useful
disagreeableness there it's like i'm
going to talk to whoever the hell i want
to
yeah i don't care what you think about
it i interviewed milo speaking of people
that you're not supposed to be talking
to recently yeah like a week ago yeah
so i take a lot of heat from that
i hasn't been broadcast yet i don't
think i'm gonna i don't think i'm going
to take a lot of heat for it you know
because it was we didn't have a
political discussion
what did i talk about logical discussion
well that's interesting i was really
curious about
how he got taken down you know when he
was talking about his his his sexual
abuse when he was a kid and defending it
in some sense like i watched that that
interview and i knew he was in trouble
as soon as he completed it i figured no
you're
you said things that you're not allowed
to say
and i think the part of it was that
see i was split in two parts watching it
partly because i was also watching it as
a clinician i thought
that it was admirable of milo to refuse
to take the victim stance because he had
been such a anti-victim
uh what would you call it agitator or
advocate right and so he said well i was
a full participant in this but then the
clinical side of me thought no
man you haven't updated your memory
since you were 14 like you're still
thinking of
adult milo as 14 year old milo and
you're not thinking about 14 year old
milo as a kid
and so that was sad for me to see that
because
often when people are traumatized
in some sense around the area of trauma
they don't mature
like it's like they get stuck well look
yeah imagine that you're on a path and
you you you come towards an obstacle
that's impenetrable
but you really need to get through it
to fully develop like it's part of what
you need to grow up but you can't so you
walk around it you know but you leave
the part of yourself that could have
matured behind there and because it
didn't deal with the challenge like this
is sort of what you were experiencing
maybe on fear factor maybe why you're
such a
what you're so emotionally affected by
triumph it's like you get defeated by
something like that you can't overcome
it there's part of you that gets stuck
there in a sense and something freud
observed like a hundred and
my damn year must be 120 years ago that
people would fixate at a certain age
because something had happened to them
or at least part of their personality
would i could see that happening with
milo and i thought that he was in a
really tough spot because he'd been
molested he didn't want to play the
victim he
yet he actually was a victim which was
the perverse goddamn thing and that you
know the way he spoke about it could
easily have been
twisted misinterpreted partly because of
his own doing into a quasi-justification
for pedophilia and then he also said
well you know that this was relatively
common practice in the gay community and
i figured he'd be cut to ribbons for for
for bringing that up but he said in the
interview it was really weird you know
he said that uh it wasn't the left
wingers that took him out
it was the conservatives
and they were bad because he he was
slated to talk speak at cpac
and uh and the straight republican types
not the trump types you know but uh but
the more
classically conservative republicans
didn't think that milo yiannopoulos was
the right kind of guy to have speaking
at cpac and so his sense is that it was
actually the
moderate right that wiped him out and so
that was wow that was interesting and i
didn't expect that
and he i we also talked a fair bit about
um
i can't tell you all of it because then
nobody has to watch the damn podcast but
um or listen to it but
you know he's he's also
shifted his viewpoint quite
substantially on what happened to him
when he was 14 and he he describes the
process he went through to kind of
rethink that not least
controversy it caused so
you know i think
well that was our conversation it lasted
a couple hours it was
you know i asked him how he was doing
and what he was planning on doing and
and that and so that was kind of
interesting to find out too but um we
never got into anything that was
remotely political and so
i was happy to have had the conversation
you know the thing about people like
milo is i don't give a damn what you say
about alex jones is the same sort of
person
i think the same thing about tommy
robinson for that matter it's like
these people are interesting
like they're strange people and they
have they have an effect on the world
and like
what are you supposed to do are you
supposed to what are you not supposed to
be curious about that
it's like yeah this is
the platform
yeah
it's the de-platforming thing like they
did they have this idea that you should
not have a differing opinion if you have
a differing opinion it should never get
a platform
and yeah well it's also
more perverse than that even it's the
idea that if you give someone like that
quote a platform so now you're willing
to talk to them that you must agree with
them merely you're conversing with them
and it's like yeah that and that's a
that's a that's a
well that guilt by association
assumption is
it's a terrible assumption what does it
mean you're only going to talk to people
who hold exactly the same ethical views
that you hold on anything on everything
yeah
it's nonsense it's like that data and
society thing that came out connecting
everybody is alt-right gateways because
they've talked to people that are on the
right you know i i tweeted that lady
when she wrote that i said
that barbara walters interviewed castro
does that make her a communist
and so it's basically how i my take on
all this stuff is there's nothing wrong
with talking to people and i feel like
milo
in a well milo you know almost has been
his own worst enemy because he's such a
provocateur and now they've turned a lot
of that stuff that he was saying as a
provocateur and they've turned it
against him
um but i think that
you and him have this one thing in
common in that you get categorized by
lazy people who are not good at nuance
and they put you in this box that other
people have created and this box is oh
this is an alt-right this this is a
conservative that this guy's a nazi this
guy's a white supremacist this guy's a
that whatever it is they put you in that
box and then
socially
you have to in order to fit into the
ideology in order to fit into this group
think
you have to sort of
accept these definitions that this
person's bad you know that that person
gavin mcginnis is a nazi milo
yiannopoulos or nazi that these people
with this these are the problem without
any real understanding of who those
people really are without any real
ground well that happened to sargon of
the cad right
carl benjamin hey by the way
we're launching our
alternative social media platform soon
okay what it going yeah it's going to be
well we we tried out the first of the
technology
i just they've debated slavoy zizek on
friday and last friday and he was
hypothetically the world's foremost
marxist philosopher although it turned
out that he wasn't really a marxist at
all he called himself a hegelian which
is actually way different than being a
marxist and so it wasn't really much of
a debate it was more me attacking the
communist manifesto for half an hour
which i found rather
rather
straightforward thing to do and then us
having a rather
peculiar and productive discussion for
about an hour and a half but anyways
think spot tested their technology so
the live stream technology and we've got
some cool features that no other
platform has so it'll be a subscription
service and so that's partly what makes
it a replacement for patreon to some
degree you know because we want to be
able to monetize creators but
we've got new different terms of service
and so the essential issue with the
terms of service will be that
once
you're on our platform
we won't take you down unless we're
ordered to by a u.s court of law
that's basically the idea so we're
trying to make an anti-censorship
platform and then we've got there's
other features too that are quite cool
and unique so for example
it's you might be interested in this
with regards to your podcast so
if you listen to
your podcast on our platform people will
be able to like pick a time in the
podcast like maybe a 30-second clip and
just mark it out and then they'll be
able to either make a written comment
about it or an auditory comment and then
send that to a friend or post it
so that the
running
continual running conversations in audio
in written form on podcast content
constantly we want to do the same thing
for youtube videos so that people can
append
their own video to any part of a video
and then distribute that to their
network or also post it so that people
can watch
you know so that
we're hoping we can get a real dialogue
we can really add dialogue to the to the
podcast and and youtube world we're also
going to do the same thing with books so
if you buy an e-book on the platform
you'll be able to annotate publicly and
so what that should mean is that every
book that's
sold on our platform that many people
purchase will become the center of
multiple conversations and we can do
that with books that are uh in the
public domain
so for example one of the books we're
going to post right away is beyond good
and evil by nietzsche and i'm going to
start annotating it you know and so what
what that should mean you know if you
look at the bible it's a good example
people have been annotating it for like
5 000 years right every verse has
god books written on it so it's just
it's incredibly expanded document that's
pulled in
thousands and thousands of people to
this collective conversation and this
platform should be able to uh
allow people to do that with
with great works of art and well and
then with also with current current
affairs and events and such as well
youtube videos and podcasts and so
it's nice looking too it it
it's got a fairly professional feel
we're hoping that we'll be able to pull
people who are interested in intelligent
conversation
specifically into this platform you know
and maybe start to pull them away from
youtube and some of the less specialized
channels hoping it's a that that plus
you know our anti-censorship stance and
to be invitation only to begin with so
that we can
well so that we can beta test it make
sure the damn thing works and that we're
not fooling ourselves about its appeal
so that's come a long ways and hopefully
i think we've got four five six people
who are interested who are lined up
reuben is gonna use it i'm gonna use it
james altucker
uh jocko willink michael shermer
i think those are oh and and uh
carl carl benjamin sargon of the cad
they'll be our first
beta testers fundamentally
that sounds awesome yeah i'm looking
forward to it man if the bloody thing
works i'd like to have a conversation
with you about it at some point because
oh for sure i'd love to try it okay okay
okay well i'll let i'll let the
developer know and um but i think the i
think the annotation feature could be
really cool
and we're also setting it up so that if
you do comment
here all the comments will be up and
down voted
and if your ratio of down votes to
upvotes
falls below 50 50
then your comments will be hidden
people will still be able to see them if
they click but you'll disappear you know
from from the main street but we don't
know if 50 50 is right we're going to
have to play with that because we're
also trying to control
stupid trolling
and i think we're going to put a minimum
length requirement on for written
comments so that you can't just say four
words like this guy's a [ __ ] idiot
you know like no
right you need that so that you know
minimum comment length is 50 words
you're going to have to put a little
thought into it even if you're being a
troll hopefully you'll be a quasi-witty
troll
so
anyways yeah that's the ultimate battle
right is trying to combat the trolls in
some sort of a way or mitigate their
their impact yeah well it's it's the
ultimate battle is to do that without
being sensorious right because you want
to
express their opinion but there's a
difference between it's subtle but
there's a difference between
productive dialogue and
and
provocation without wit
for the purpose of causing trouble
there's so many people out there that
are just bored and that's what they use
the internet for they're at work they're
in a cubicle all day and they get their
jollies out of just [ __ ] with people
online
and my producer jamie he has a friend
who does that i mean this is what this
friend does he has a bunch of accounts
and he just trolls people he tries to
troll celebrities and he tries to get
them to respond to him he says mean
things to them and
you know that's how he
that's how he entertains himself
same dark side that
that was manifesting up to a much
greater degree in bill cosby
you know wow right guys the guy he's
also depressed he's also a depressed guy
he's a failure in life and you know he's
everything you would expect yeah someone
who uses that kind of time for
recreation right so you know the issue
with him is like he should take some of
that
so if he would admit to himself his
aggression
if he'd come to terms with it
he could take that damn aggression and
he could integrate it into his
personality
and that would make him able to focus on
his life
you know like you said when you you know
you started your your martial arts
fighting
that you were obsessed hey
and you were also sick of being pushed
around in all of that and you were like
willing to do something about it but
obviously and it's obvious just talking
to you that
the aggressive part of your character is
like deeply integrated inside of you
it's not hiding out in some corner doing
stupid things that you know you're not
paying attention to it's right there at
hand and you get a guy like the one
you're talking about he's split into
meek and depressed and ineffectual on
the one hand and cruel and resentful and
bitter another if those two things would
marry
you know he'd get half his personality
back and and maybe some of his dynamism
and so it's a real waste of time
well i think a lot of people just feel
just totally powerless and they feel
like this is the only way they can
affect others is by reaching out and
trolling or saying mean things and i
think that many people take these
terrible paths and lives in their lives
which are not productive and they don't
they don't feel good about it they don't
they don't respond well to whatever
they're doing with their life and they
have this constant state of anxiety it's
like throws quote most men live lives of
quiet desperation
except the trolls live life is of noisy
desperation
yeah that's what the internet that's
what the internet has allowed
yes jordan i gotta wrap this up i gotta
get out of here unfortunately this is a
long and wonderful conversation though
like we always have hey well we damn
caught up you got 30 seconds
yes yeah okay well let's send it off i
want to know what okay what
what are you up to next man like what do
you want to have happen you've got this
crazy reach you've got this crazy
platform
what's what what's what's on your
horizon
i just what you're doing
no
no i just enjoy what i'm doing i'd like
to continue doing what i'm doing i'm
very happy that people enjoy the show
i'm very very happy that it's affecting
people in a positive way that they're
getting inspiration out of it and
they're getting information and
entertainment and education
and uh it means the world to me i love
it i love doing the podcast i love doing
stand-up i love everything that i'm
doing i mean i'm very very happy with my
my career and family life i couldn't be
happier so i just like to keep doing
what i'm doing i don't have any crazy
aspirations
other than
continuing to get better at everything
that i try to work at
yeah well that's that's a crazy
aspiration man because you
well you've got a lot of things going
for you that are very very unlikely you
know and to
and to hope i don't mean to hope that
they'll get better but to continue to
work to get those better that seems like
sufficient aspiration from my
perspective so look if you work at
anything if you work at anything you're
trying to improve and if you there's
there's you know there's always room
there's always room for improvement and
everything yep and every personality and
your work and everything and that's what
i strive for i strive for improvement
yeah well that edge of improvement's a
good place to be look i wanted also to
thank you
just just so you know what you know
you're especially that first interview
you did with me
that was really helpful to me and i mean
i've enjoyed all the talks that we've
had and
and they've been really productive and
they've they've had a
well very big impact on my life but lots
of people have watched them
and so
they seem to it seems to me that we've
had a pretty productive
series of interactions but uh i do
you'll do all your some some thanks and
also thanks for coming on this podcast
man it was really my pleasure
and i will definitely talk to you about
think spot if once we get it going and
see that it works because it's look i
didn't have any hope for its success
when it first you know it was a little
ugly baby thing
because
you know it's too impossible but
it's looking pretty damn good and it's
got some cool features so it'd be nice
to have a censorship censorship-free
platform if we could figure out how to
do that
that sounds very exciting i'm very
interested i can't wait to try it
all right man
thank you jordan hey thanks a lot
my pleasure okay good luck with your
improvement and i'm looking for thank
you comedy special
thank you my brother take care ciao